filles en live il est très exactement
19h29 nous sommes en direct pour une
journée marquée on le sait par cette
attaque islamiste à nice ce matin mais
également et bien par cette veille dur
confinement qu'on va suivre bien toute
la soirée puisque le gouvernement avec
jean castex à partir de 18h30 donc bien
d'ici quelques minutes devrait détailler
les différentes mesures que l'on va
pouvoir et bien observé lors de ce
nouveau confinement le deuxième on va
suivre je vous le disais en direct ces
différentes annonces
merci à vous d'être avec nous sur le
figaro sur la page principale du figaro
sur fait sur youtube mais également sur
twitch on va suivre en direct je vous le
disais cette cette soirée et vous allez
le voir le pupitre est déjà prêt juste
derrière moi on attend bien les
différents membres du gouvernement qui
vont se présenter pour nous annoncer les
différentes mesures qui seront prises
alors on a déjà eu pas mal de détails
hier soir avec le président de la
république mais on devrait en avoir
beaucoup plus avec les différents
ministres chacun est bien répartie selon
leur domaine avec et bien les ministres
de l'éducation de l'économie de
l'intérieur
la ministre du travail mais également le
ministre de la santé qui devrait nous
apporter beaucoup plus de détails
beaucoup plus de précisions sur ce qui
doit arriver à partir de demain pour au
minimum quatre semaines
on ne sait certaines mesures devraient
être annoncées au bout de deux semaines
si jamais des signes positifs sont à
observer mais ce que l'on va pouvoir et
bien vivre pendant ces quatre prochaines
semaines et on sera ensemble pour le
vivre sur figaro live et bien ce sera
présenté dans les quelques minutes qui
suivent l'occasion pour moi de venir
vous de vous saluer puisque je vous le
disais nous sommes en direct sur la page
principale du figaro mais également sur
twitter et sur youtube pourrait bien
vous présenter en direct et aussi
répondre à vos questions
puisque juste après ces annonces nous
serons avec sophie de tarlé rédactrice
en chef au figaro étudiant pour et bien
on apprendre un peu plus et surtout
avoir un petit peu ces réactions après
les annonces notamment de jean michel
blanquer r bonjour à vous sur youtube je
vois que vous
déjà très nombreux à nous suivre vous
êtes plus de 2000 je vais essayer de
dents salué quelques-uns d'entre vous
mais ma course kyle flame moussa miss
bunny lee dit le loup voilà tout le
monde mr cactus également merci à tous
d'être avec nous n'hésitez pas ben voila
si vous avez des réactions ou des
questions à nous poser n'hésitez pas à
nous les poser ce sera avec plaisir on
va bien essayé de suivre un peu ce qui
se dit si vous êtes étudiant il va
rester avec nous puisque comme je vous
le disais après on va revenir un petit
peu sur les les annonces de jean michel
blanquer qui devrait faire son
apparition avec les différents ministres
dans quelques minutes durant quelques
minutes pardon et on prendra toutes les
réactions en direct
voilà on attend encore les ministres
bonjour à vous sur twitch qui nous
suivaient bonjour théo 512 road in art
va j'espère ne pas écorcher votre nom
lollipop 365
yauque nc bat merci à tous d'être avec
nous n'hésitez pas à réagir
bonjour c'est doc salle je vous salue
également sur sur tweets je vous
remercie du fall au white / amy merci à
tous d'être avec nous on prend bien
évidemment tous vos commentaires voilà
le premier ministre qui devrait faire
son apparition
je vais vous laisser suivre les
différentes déclarations dès maintenant
bonne séance
mesdames et messieurs se maintenant en
la basilique notre dame de l'assomption
à nice aux alentours de 9 heures
trois de nos compatriotes ont été
assassinés à l'armé blanche dans des
circonstances dangereuses
en ces moments tragiques nos premières
pensées vont à la famille à leurs
proches aux paroissiens de nice mais
aussi plus largement à tous les
catholiques qui ont été frappés en plein
coeur
à quelques jours de la fête de la
toussaint
je veux leur dire ici que la nation
partage leur douleur et leur immense et
moscou
cette attaque aussi lâche que barbare en
deuil
une nouvelle fois le pays tout entier
permettez moi de saluer devant vous
l'intervention immédiate de nos forces
de sécurité intérieure la police
nationale le raid et tout
particulièrement les policiers
municipaux de nice qui ont procédé à la
neutralisation très rapide du terrorisme
le procureur national anti terroristes
et saisi la réforme du gouvernement sera
ferme un placard les immédiate
j'ai d'ores et déjà décidé de porter le
plan vigipirate à son niveau le plus
élevé c'est-à-dire le niveau urgence
attentat sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
à ce titre la protection des bâtiments
publics des services publics et des
lieux de culte sera renforcée et la
mobilisation des forces de sécurité sera
accrue le dispositif sentinelle sur
décision du président de la république
va passer de 3000 à 7000 militaires
demain un conseil de défense a été
convoqué par le chef de l'état cette
attaque ignoble vient nous frapper alors
que nous sommes par ailleurs confronté à
une crise sanitaire sans précédent
la lutte contre le terrorisme nous la
menons de front avec la lutte contre
l'épidémie qui frappe elle aussi très
durement notre prix le président de la
république s'est exprimé hier devant la
nation pour annoncer aux françaises et
aux français les mesures décidées afin
de faire face à la violence de la
deuxième vague épidémique
il m'appartient désormais de vous en
préciser avec les ministres concernés
les modalités de fonctionnement et de
déploie l'accélération de la circulation
du virus
vous la voyez sur l'écran frappe avec la
même brutalité toute l'europe
tout le monde avait intégré le risque
d'une deuxième vague mais personne
n'avait prévu une flambée si violente
est si rapide et d'ailleurs la plupart
des pays européens sont aussi conduit à
prendre comme nous
des mesures de restriction en france
contrairement à la première vague ont
toutes nos régions et toutes les
catégories d'âge sont touchées puisque
le virus accélère alors nous devons
accélérer également l'objectif est
simple protéger la santé de nos
concitoyens en cassant par tous moyens
la spirale épidémique
c'est la raison pour laquelle le présent
la république a décidé d'imposer un
confinement adapté à l'échelle du pays
entier à partir de ce soir minuit et
jusqu'au 1er décembre
je le dis clairement il n'y a pas
d'autre solution pour autant les
modalités et le contour de ce nouveau
confinement ne seront pas ceux de mars
car nous avons appris de la première
vague et nous en tirons les
enseignements
nous veillerons en particulier à mieux
préserver l'essentiel notre droit se
soigner travailler s'éduquer se former à
compter de ce soir minuit le confinement
sera d
été sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
seule exception pour les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer où le virus
circule moins vite
ce dispositif ne sera appliqué qu'à
lamartine des tests seront en revanche
exigé au départ ou à l'arrivée de ces
territoires afin d'éviter tout risque de
diffusion du virus
beaucoup des règles que vous avez connu
en mars et en avril seront reconduites
à partir de demain
la première chose c'est que vous ne
pourrez quitter votre domicile que pour
cette certaine raison est muni d'une
attestation pour le prouver
comme pendant le confinement vous
pourrez ainsi sortir pour faire vos
courses alimentaires pour vous rares ou
revenir de votre lieu de travail et
exercez votre activité professionnelle
si vous n'êtes pas en capacité de le
faire en télétravail pour des motifs
médicaux vous rendre à l'hôpital
les un professionnel de santé dans une
pharmacie pour des motifs familiaux
impérieux pour l'assistance aux
personnes vulnérables et précaires
notamment aux personnes en situation de
handicap pour une convocation judiciaire
ou administrative pour la participation
à des missions d'intérêt général sur
demande de l'autorité administrative
cela concerne par exemple les marottes
des associations de lutte contre la
pauvreté ou les distributions dead
alimentaires à domicile pour un
déplacement d'une heure maximum pour
faire de l'activité physique pour
prendre l'air ou pour promener vos
animaux domestiques
ces déplacements ne pourront pas
dépasser ou se faire au delà d'un rayon
d'un kilomètre du domicile
je rappelle que pour les activités fils
seuls les pratiques individuelles et de
plein air comme le jogging sauront
autorisé dans ce cadre précis les salles
de sport et les gymnases seront fermées
et les sports collectifs de plein air le
foot le basket le rugby et c'est
interdit en revanche contrairement au
printemps les parts jardins forêts
plages resteront ouverts comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure des
autorisations supplémentaires sont
prévus par rapport au corps finement de
mars pour accompagner à l'enfant à
l'école ou à les rechercher pour se
rendre dans un service public ou chez un
opérateur assurant une mission de
service public la cave l'assurance
maladie pour l'emploi les maisons
départementales pour les personnes
handicapées un rendez vous à la mairie
ou à la préfecture
je rappelle à ce titre que les guichets
de la poste et les guichets de banques
resteront également ouverts
vous pourrez allez vous formez
uniquement quand cela n'est pas possible
à distance vous présenter à un examen ou
un concours par exemple les examens du
permis de conduire et donc par
différence tous les autres déplacements
sont interdits ainsi il ne vous est pas
possible d'aller chez des amis ou de
recevoir de la famille à la maison dans
la journée comme le soir la semaine et
le week-end
il ne vous est a fortiori pas possible
de vous déplacer au delà d'un kilomètre
de chez vous en dehors des motifs prévus
il ne sera pas possible davantage de
voyager au sein du territoire national y
compris d'une résidence principale vers
une résidence secondaire
il y aura néanmoins une tolérance ce
week end pour le retour des vacances de
la toussaint pour chaque sortie
vous devrez vous munir d'une attestation
comme au printemps et vous trouverez dès
à présent sur le site
du gouvernement et sur l'application
tous antico vide
cette attestation afin de faciliter la
vie quotidienne
votre vie quotidienne deux attestations
permanente pourront également être
délivrée par votre employeur pour les
déplacements entre le domicile et le
travail par l'établissement scolaire de
vos enfants pour les déplacements
domicile école les fonctionnaires et des
indépendants pourront présenter leur
carte professionnelle ou tout autre
justificatif d'activité professionnelle
une amende forfaitaire de 135 euros sera
appliquée en cas de non-respect du
confinement et si vous ne pouvez pas
présenté de justificatifs
alors que vous êtes contrôlés en dehors
de votre domicile
enfin concernant nos frontières les
frontières intérieures à l'espace
européen demeureront ouvertes
en revanche les frontières extérieures
seront fermées sauf pour les
déplacements des ressortissants français
et des résidents en france sous couvert
de la pratique de tests toute personne
arrivant sur le territoire devra en
effet faire la preuve d'un test négatif
réalisé 72 heures en avance et pour ceux
qui ne disposeraient pas du résultat
d'un test un test à l'arrivée sera
imposée comme au printemps
l'essentiel des établissements recevant
du public seront fermés les bars et les
restaurants les commerces autre que de
première nécessité d salle polyvalente
et salle de conférence les salles de
spectacle et les cinémas les salles de
sport les parcs d'attraction les salons
foires et expositions
là encore vous trouverez la liste
complète de ces établissements sur le
site du gouvernement
les dérogations qui avait été établi au
printemps seront maintenus
les commerces alimentaires essentiels
les stations service et les garages les
laveries et blanchisserie
les magasins de journaux et les tabacs
les opticiens certains magasins
spécialisés l'équipement informatique
les télécommunications la location de
voitures et d'équipements resteront
ouverts par rapport au confinement de
mars tous les commerces de gros les
magasins et les jardineries ainsi afin
que pardon que les professionnels
puissent continuer de s'approvisionner
les crèches et les établissements
scolaires jusqu'au lycée inclut les
établissements périscolaire l'ours
qu'ils assurent la garde d'enfants le
soir après l'école et les centres de
loisirs le mercredi
en revanche les établissements qui
proposent des activités extra scolaires
sportives ou artistiques comme les
conservatoires ou les clubs de sport
sont fermés
les hôtels qui peuvent garder une petite
activité pour les déplacements
professionnels indispensables mais les
restaurants dans ces hôtels seront
fermés seul le room service pouvant
fonctionner tous les services de
transports en commun resteront ouverts
et leur niveau de service devra être
maintenue
j'ajoute quelques précisions l'ensemble
de ces établissements autorisés à ouvrir
devront appliquer les protocoles
sanitaires en vigueur notamment la mise
en place de georges les commerces fermés
de même que les restaurants ne pourront
pas accueillir du public mais pourront
continuer de fonctionner pour les
activités de livraison et le retrait de
commandes tous les rassemblements sont
interdits sur la voie publique à
l'exception des manifestations
revendicatives déclaré auprès de la
préfecture
en ce qui concerne les lieux de culte
ils resteront ouverts en revanche les
cérémonies religieuses seront interdites
sauf pour les enterrements dans la
limite
30 personnes et pour les mariages dans
la limite de six personnes
une tolérance sera appliquée pour les
cérémonies prévues ce week end de la
toussaint ainsi que pour les
déplacements dans les cimetières et les
commerces de fleurs je vous invite à
vous rendre sur le site du gouvernement
pour retrouver la liste exhaustive des
établissements pouvoir rester ouverts
parce que nous avons appris de la
première vague ce confinement sera
adapté sur deux points essentiels
l'école et le travail en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement je les dis les crèches
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
resteront ouverts avec des protocoles
sanitaires renforcés notamment le port
du masque des six ans afin de ne laisser
aucun enfant sur le bord du chemin tout
en protégeant nos enseignants je demande
à jean michel blanquer ministre chargé
de l'éducation nationale de vous
apporter les précisions nécessaires
merci monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république l'a annoncé
hier vous venez de le rappeler
aujourd'hui pendant le nouveau
confinement les écoles les collèges et
les lycées resteront ouverts nous avons
nous le savons tous à protéger
l'éducation de nos enfants tout
particulièrement les plus fragiles
puisque nous l'avons vu lors du premier
confinement malgré l'engagement de nos
professeurs dans l'enseignement à
distance
nous savons que la fermeture des écoles
et des établissements entraîne
l'aggravation des retards scolaires et
nous ne voulons pas cela nous ne voulons
pas d'écart entre les élèves nous
voulons que les élèves puissent profiter
de l'école l'épidémie ne saurait priver
durablement les enfants de tout lien
avec l'école et nous ne pouvons pas
laisser la crise sanitaire entraîné des
retards qui sont ensuite susceptibles de
décrochage au delà des conséquences
éducative
nous savons aussi que le confinement
peut avoir pour les enfants des
conséquences sur leur développement
psychique sur leur développement
physique et même sur le sur leur santé
c'est d'ailleurs la société française de
pédiatrie qui le dit et que nous suivons
il faut dire aussi que très souvent les
contaminations qui peuvent exister se
passe en dehors de l'établissement
scolaire
autrement dit il faut bien se dire que
lorsque les enfants ne sont pas à
l'école ils ont des activités qui
souvent sont bien plus contaminantes
notamment dans le cercle privé
nous avons donc le devoir et ce devoir
être absolument fondamental de maintenir
ouverte notre école
tant que nous le pourrons il y va de
l'avenir de l'éducation de l'avenir de
notre jeunesse et donc de l'avenir de
notre pays pour les la période actuelle
nous savons déjà que depuis la rentrée
de septembre
l'application du protocole sanitaire a
abouti à ce qu'il y ait peu de
contamination en milieu scolaire je
rappelle les chiffres actuellement c'est
à dire au moment où les vacances ont
commencé il y avait 27 structures
scolaires fermés sur les 61 mille cinq
cents que compte le pays
c'est à dire 0 04 % de fermeture il y
avait 2 193 classes fermées ce qui
correspond à 0 06 % le nombre de cas qu
au vide sur les sept derniers jours
s'établissait à 8200 23 élèves
rappelons qu'il ya 12 millions 400 mille
élèves dans notre pays donc 0.07 pour
les s'agissant des personnels
nous avions recensé sur les sept
derniers jours 2063 cas pour un million
deux cent mille personnes soit 0 18%
je continuerai à actualiser ces chiffres
évidemment au cours des prochaines
semaines
d'autant plus que nous aurons une
politique de tests volontariste avec une
priorité pour les personnels éducatifs
de l'éducation nationale et des
collectivités locales pour être testés
sur le lieux scolaires ou non l'école
est donc en réalité un espace sécurisé
parce qu'on ne rrespectent plus les
règles sanitaires qu'ailleurs et nous
continuerons donc à fermer des
structures chaque fois que ce sera
nécessaire
sur la base des critères fixés par les
autorités sanitaires
et chaque fois que nous fermerons nous
appliquerons notre protocole de
continuité pédagogique que nous avons
déjà appliqué ces derniers temps avec la
possibilité d'un enseignement à distance
qui se déclenche immédiatement le
protocole sanitaire qui va s'appliquer
maintenant pour les écoles et les
établissements et donc durci comme l'a
dit le premier ministre son schéma de
base a été préparée depuis le mois de
juillet avec les autorités sanitaires
dans l'hypothèse d'un retour d'une
circulation très active du virus
il est transmis aujourd'hui à tous les
responsables de l'éducation nationale
locaux ce protocole permettra l'accueil
de tous les élèves sur l'ensemble du
temps scolaire il s'appuie sur les
dernières recommandations du haut
conseil à la santé publique
j'ai eu aujourd'hui même des échanges
avec les organisations syndicales mais
aussi avec les associations d'élus
les organisations syndicales m'ont fait
part d'un certain nombre de demandes que
j'essaierai de satisfaire au maximum je
pense en particulier aux personnels
vulnérables qui bien sûr n'ont pas à
venir danser semaine là en fonction
d'ailleurs d'une typologie établie par
le ministère de la fonction publique
cette typologie sera rendu public demain
avec les associations d'élus nous avons
pu avoir
là aussi un dialogue constructif elles
ont l'expérience de ces protocoles durci
puisque rappelons nous qu'au mois de mai
et juin les protocoles était encore plus
dur si sur le plan notamment des
conditions d'hygiène et du nettoyage
très régulier des locaux conformément
donc aux derniers avis du haut conseil
le masque devient obligatoire pour tous
les élèves à partir du cours
préparatoire
le premier ministre l'a dit à l'instant
afin que ces élèves et leurs professeurs
se prémunissent au maximum de tout
risque de contagion hésiter éventuelles
même si nous savons que la contagiosité
des petits enfants vers les adultes et
semble-t-il faible j'invite donc tous
les parents à équiper leurs enfants et
comme c'est déjà le cas au collège et au
lycée
des masques seront prévues dans les
écoles en cas d'oubli ou de difficultés
économiques d'une famille pour se
procurer de telles masses au niveau du
lycée une souplesse sera laissée aux
chefs d'établissement pour
l'organisation du protocole le protocole
de continuité pédagogique permet en
particulier d'envisager de
l'enseignement à distance pour les
élèves vulnérables ou pour des groupes
d'élèves
d'autre part la semaine prochaine les
écoles et les établissements
s'organiseront afin de limiter au
maximum le brassage entre les différents
niveaux d'élèves de manière très
concrète et bien sûr cela est précisé
dans les documents mais pour résumer il
ya quatre points principaux
l'arrivée le départ des élèves dans
l'établissement ils seront autant que
possible étalé dans le temps
cela dépend évidemment du nombre
d'élèves accueillis
il y aura donc des souplesses locales et
là aussi un travail entre l'éducation
nationale et les collectivités locales
la circulation des élèves dans le
bâtiment les déplacements des élèves
seront limités au maximum
ainsi dans le second degré une seule
salle sera attribué à chaque classe dans
la mesure du possible à l'exception des
salles spécialisées et des ateliers
en troisième lieu les récréations seront
organisées par groupes avec un respect
maximale des gestes barrières
lorsqu'elles sont trop difficiles à
organiser ainsi elles peuvent être
remplacés par des temps de pause en
classe enfin en quatrième lieu la
restauration scolaire est maintenue pour
des raisons sociales en particulier en
veillant à espacer chaque élève d'un
mètre autant que possible quand cette
distanciation pourra être respecté les
élèves d'une même classe ou d'un même
niveau déjeuneront ensemble au même
endroit chaque jour et espaces et des
autres groupes
l'aération et la ventilation des classes
seront également renforcés comme la
désinfection des locaux et des matériels
le nettoyage des salles et des tables
sera réalisée tous les jours celui des
surfaces les plus fréquemment touchés
comme les poignées de portes sera
réalisé plusieurs fois par jour
c'est un protocole d'accord qui rappelle
ce que nous faisions en juin le lavage
des mains les gestes barrière le respect
de la distanciation physique quand elle
est possible feront l'objet d'une
vigilance accrue
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires
s'appliqueront pour l'accueil
périscolaire des enfants dont le premier
ministre a parlé et c'est donc les mêmes
règles que l'on retrouvera dans
l'activité périscolaire
je voudrais pour conclure remercié les
professeurs remercier l'ensemble des
personnels de l'éducation nationale mais
aussi les personnels des collectivités
locales tout ce qui contribue au service
public de l'éducation nationale c'est
non seulement un effort mais un
engagement qui leur est demandé
cet effort ils ont su accomplir depuis
mois de septembre il l'avait accompli
pendant leur confinement et de
déconfinement ils ont droit à la
reconnaissance de la nation
je veux leur exprimer aujourd'hui parce
que ce qui se joue est essentiel pour
notre jeunesse nos enfants nos
adolescents comme l'a dit le président
de la république sont notre priorité
numéro un dans cette période de vie du
pays je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre pour les
universités et établissements
d'enseignement supérieur la règle sera
le distance yale dans les universités et
dans tous ses établissements les cours
devront être assurées en ligne seuls les
travaux pratiques et enseignement
professionnel nécessitant du matériel
spécialisés pourront se poursuivre en
présentiel les examens et les concours
pourront se tenir avec un protocole
renforcé les restaurants universitaires
pourront continuer à fonctionner mais
uniquement pour des repas à emporter les
bibliothèques universitaires seront
ouvertes sur rendez-vous et dans le
respect d'une jauge les activités de
recherche doivent également se
poursuivre en télétravail
quand c'est possible mais également en
présentiel quand cela ne l'est pas dans
le milieu professionnel
le principe que les activités se
poursuivent
toutes les entreprises qui ne sont pas
fermées administrativement doivent
pouvoir continuer à fonctionner le plus
normalement possible
je pense à toutes les activités de
service aux bureaux d'études à
l'industrie au btp aux activités
agricoles etc
il en sera évidemment de même pour tous
les professionnels du soin ce du service
à la personne notamment de l'aide à
domicile ou de la garde d'enfants il
sera possible aussi pour les
professionnels de la culture et du sport
de continuer le travail préparatoire au
spectacle les répétitions entraînement
enregistrements et tournage partout où
cela sera possible
le télétravail devrait être la règle
dans les conditions que la ministre du
travail vous présentera dans un instant
ainsi tous les fonctionnaires
travailleront en télétravail pour toutes
les activités qui le permettent en
présentiel pour le res s'agissant
notamment des activités de guichet je
pense ici bien sûr aux soignants aux
enseignants et aux forces de l'ordre
mais plus généralement à l'ensemble des
agents publics qui sont en première
ligne dans les services publics pour les
entreprises fermées ou qui rencontrent
des difficultés le recours au chômage
partiel sera maintenue dans les
conditions exceptionnelles qui prévalait
jusqu'à présent je laisse la parole à
elisabeth board pour vous préciser tous
ces différents éléments
merci monsieur premier ministre bonsoir
à toutes et à tous comme l'a dit le
premier ministre ce matin
nous devons tout faire pour éviter de
connaître une chute de l'activité
économique aussi brutale qu'au printemps
dernier
ainsi tous ceux dont les activités ne
sont pas contraintes de fermer doivent
continuer à travailler
contrairement au printemps dernier nous
sommes mieux armés face à l'épidémie
tous les secteurs ont défini des
protocoles sanitaires très strictes qui
sont protecteurs pour la santé des
salariés
néanmoins dans la situation actuelle
nous devons encore réduire les
interactions sociales et les
déplacements
cela signifie que dans toutes les
entreprises les travailleurs que ce soit
des salariés comme des indépendants dont
les activités peuvent être exercés à
distance doivent télétravail et le
télétravail n'est pas une option
cette obligation sera inscrite dans la
nouvelle version du protocole national
en entreprise la règle est la suivante
premier cas de figure un travailleur qui
peut effectuer toutes ces tâches en
télétravail doit le faire cinq jours sur
cinq
deuxième cas de figure ceux qui ne
peuvent pas effectuer toutes leurs
tâches à distance peuvent se rendre une
partie de leurs tentes sur le lieu de
travail
c'est le cas par exemple dans un bureau
d'études pour un ingénieur ou un
technicien pour un architecte qui a
besoin d'équipements spécifiques pour
travailler toutefois l'organisation du
travail doit permettre de regrouper ses
activités pour limiter les déplacements
troisième cas de figure certains métiers
ne peuvent être réalisées à distance
je pense par exemple aux salariés des
commerces qui reste ouvert mais aussi
aux chefs de chantier aux ouvriers du
btp aux agriculteurs ou encore à tous
les intervenants à domicile pour se
rendre sur le lieu de travail
il sera nécessaire de disposer d'une
attestation de l'employeur des
employeurs seront par ailleurs tenue d'
aménager des horaires d'arrivée et de
départ afin de limiter l'affluence aux
heures de pointe
en complément les réunions en audio ou
visioconférence doivent constituer la
règle les moments de convivialité en
entreprise ne sont pas autorisés
les restaurants d'entreprises sont
maintenues avec un protocole renforcé
des employeurs doivent inciter leurs
salariés à télécharger tout senti qu
vide pour faciliter le suivi des cas
contactez le nouveau protocole sera mis
en ligne dès ce soir après le retour des
partenaires sociaux que nous avons
consultés il sera accessible à tous sur
le site du ministère du travail
les modalités de mise en oeuvre seront
discutés avec les représentants des
salariés au sein des entreprises
vous l'avez compris contrairement au
mois de mars dernier l'activité se
poursuivra dans de nombreux secteurs de
notre économie
mais comme au mois de mars l'etat sera
aux côtés des entreprises et des
salariés impactés par ces nouvelles
mesures sanitaires tous les secteurs
protégés ou les secteurs qui font
l'objet d'une fermeture administrative
[Musique]
bénéficient de l'activité partielle avec
un reste à charge nul pour l'employeur
c'est par exemple le cas de tous les
commerces de proximité pour les autres
secteurs le dispositif d'activité
partielle sera maintenu et prolongée aux
conditions actuelles jusqu'au 31
décembre
dans cette période de crise je veux
assurer les françaises et les français
que nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
pour protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois et la santé de tous les
travailleurs
je vous remercie merci beaucoup je les
dis nous sommes parfaitement conscients
des conséquences économiques et sociales
de la mise en oeuvre de telles mesures
je comprends la difficulté immense le
sentiment d'injustice est parfois la
détresse qui touche ce que dans un souci
de respect des règles sanitaires
on empêche de travailler les
restaurateurs un grand nombre de
commerçants les patrons de cafés et de
barres tous les acteurs de l'économie du
sport de la culture de l'événementiel je
pense aussi à ceux dans l'activité qui
sans être interdites subissent de plein
fouet les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire le tourisme l'hôtellerie
l'aéronautique et l'automobile les
chauffeurs de taxi l'état a déployé
depuis le début de la crise des mesures
de soutien exceptionnelles en renforçant
notamment le fonds de solidarité
les dispositifs d'activité partielle
on vient d'en parler les exonérations de
charge renforcée et les prêts garantis
par
l'état ces aides ont déjà été renforcées
à la suite des dernières mesures prises
lors du couvre-feu le passage à une
nouvelle étape va nous conduire non
seulement à les pérenniser
mais également à les compléter com va
vous le présenter le ministre chargé de
l'économie
bruno le maire comme vient de le
rappeler le premier ministre ce
confinement est un coup dur pour toutes
les entreprises qui vont être fermés à
compter de demain
je pense en particulier aux deux cent
mille commerces qui vont être obligés de
fermer
nous voulons leur dire que le soutien
économique de l'état sera encore plus
fort que lors du premier confinement
tout simplement parce que les
entreprises ont été fragilisés par la
première vague fragilisé par le climat
d'incertitude et qu'elles ont besoin de
notre soutien total financier et moral
ce soutien leur est acquis comme lors du
premier confinement nous serons à leur
écoute tous les jours dès aujourd'hui
j'ai décidé de rétablir la cellule de
continuité économique que nous avions
mise en place en mars
j'ai repris les réunions hebdomadaires
avec la grande distribution avec les
économistes avec les banques avec les
secteurs industriels pour faire un point
régulier et pour ajuster les dispositifs
si nécessaire j'ai par ailleurs échangé
dès aujourd'hui avec mon homologue
allemand olaf scholz avec un président
de l'eurogroupe pascal de nouilles ou
avec la président de la banque centrale
européenne christine lagarde afin de
m'assurer du soutien européen notre
économie et de faire le point sur la
situation économique en europe
j'ai également échangé à votre prono
monologue américain steven minot chine
pour coordonner nos réponses
d'économique à la demande du premier
ministre et du président de la
république nous avons renforcé tous les
dispositifs de soutien aux entreprises
le fonds de solidarité d'abord il sera
réactivée pour toutes les entreprises
sans exception et massivement renforcée
pour la durée du confinement
je rappelle que c'est un soutien vital
pour toutes les petites entreprises pour
les indépendants les artisans les
commerçants
je pense évidemment aux restaurateurs
aux patrons de bars aux coiffeurs aux
magasins de vêtements aux libraires je
pense aussi à tous ceux qui font une
grande partie de leur chiffre à noël et
qui ont fait des stocks au cours des
semaines passées les commerces de jeux
et de jouets les parfumeries d
horlogerie et bijouterie
nous allons donc renforcer massivement
ce dispositif afin que tous les cas de
figure soit couvert toutes les
entreprises et tous les commerces qui
sont fermées par décision administrative
pourront recevoir une indemnisation
allant jusqu'à dix mille euros
cela concernera les entreprises non plus
jusqu'à 10 mai jusqu'à 50 salariés
peu importe le secteur d'activité peu
importe le secteur géographique toute
entreprise d'au moins 50 salariés fermés
à partir de demain a droit à une
indemnisation jusqu'à 10000 euros pour
les entreprises des secteurs spécifiques
du tourisme de l'événementiel la culture
du sport qui sont plus particulièrement
touchées depuis des semaines
même si elle ne ferme pas si elles
subissent une perte de chiffre
d'affaires d'au moins 50%
elles bénéficieront également de cette
indemnisation
jusqu'à 10000 euros un exemple les
hôtels ne sont pas fermées mais
évidemment ils ont des pertes de chiffre
d'affaires très élevés ils pourront être
indemnisés jusqu'à hauteur de 10000
euros
enfin toutes les autres entreprises tous
secteurs confondus qui reste ouverte
mais qui sont évidemment impacté par le
confinement en premier un indépendant
qui aujourd'hui à moins de clients à
moins d'activités toutes ces autres
entreprises dès lors qu'elles ont moins
de 50 salariés et qu'elles subissent
une perte de plus de 50% de leur chiffre
d'affaires ou en droit à une
indemnisation jusqu'à 1500 euros par
mois
c'est ce qui existait au mois de mars
cette aide permettra notamment de
soutenir tous les indépendants qui
aujourd'hui n'ont absolument aucune
ressource financière
ce fonds de solidarité sera l'un des
filets de sécurité que nous leur
proposons le renforcement massif de ce
fonds de solidarité il se lit dans les
chiffres
nous allons consacrer six milliards
d'euros par mois de confinement à ce
nouveau fonds de solidarité
c'est l'équivalent de ce qui a été
dépensé pour le fonds de solidarité
depuis le mois de mars
en un mois nous allons dépenser autant
sur le fond fait d'arrêter que tout ce
que nous avions dépensé pour ce même
fonds depuis le mois de mars
c'est le témoignage du soutien total
financier et moral de l'état s'agissant
des exonérations et des reports de
cotisations sociales
là aussi même objectif et même pratiquer
toutes les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés qui sont fermées
administrativement auront une
exonération totale de leurs cotisations
sociales
s'agissant des entreprises du tourisme
de l'événementiel et même catégorie que
précédemment dès lors qu'elles perdent
50 % leur chiffre d'affaires elles
auront le droit également à une
exonération totale de leurs cotisations
sociales
s'agissant des travailleurs indépendants
les prélèvements seront automatiquement
suspendus et n'auront aucune démarche
administrative à faire ceux qui sont
fermés bénéficieront évidemment comme
les autres d'exonération totale
je veux dire aussi à tous ceux qui ont
demandé un étalement auprès des urssaf
avant le confinement qui sont en
négociation avec les urssaf pour des
étalements qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
trois ans elles pourront aussi
bénéficier d'une remise au cas par cas
si elles sont en grave difficulté
financière je sais que c'est une
préoccupation très independent très
importante de beaucoup de travailleurs
indépendants troisième soutient qu'ils
avaient été apportées qui va être
massivement renforcée
et prêts garantis par l'état et les
prêts directs de l'état que nous mettons
en place
comme annoncé il y a quelques jours par
le premier ministre les entreprises
pourront désormais contracter un prêt
garanti par l'état n'ont pas jusqu'au 31
décembre 2020 mais jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
elles ont donc six mois supplémentaires
pour contracter un prêt garanti par
l'état l'amortissement de ce prêt
garanti par l'état pourra être étalé
entre une et cinq années supplémentaires
pour toutes celles qui ont besoin de
temps et de visibilité
ils le feront à des taux que j'ai
négocié fédération bancaire française
compris entre 1 et 2 5 % maximum
garantie de l'état comprise et nous
veillerons à ce que toutes les
succursales bancaires
toutes les agences à cordes bien ces
taux attractifs aux entreprises qui en
auraient besoin
je sais également que certaines
entreprises ne seront pas en mesure de
rembourser leur prêt au 1er mars 2021 et
que c'est là aussi un sujet d'inquiétude
et que là aussi nous voulons répondre à
cette angoisse de nos entrepreneurs qui
voit arriver l'échéance et qui se dit je
ne vais pas pouvoir rembourser
eh bien il pourra obtenir un nouveau
différé de remboursement d'un an
supplémentaire soit deux années au total
de différer avant de commencer le
remboursement de son prêt concrètement
un restaurateur un fleuriste un
carrossier un libraire qui ne serait pas
en mesure de rembourser son prêt garanti
à partir de mars 2021 pourra après
examen par la banque attendre 2022 avant
de commencer le remboursement du capital
de son prêt garanti par l'état et je
précise que la fédération bancaire
française s'est engagée à examiner avec
beaucoup de bienveillance toutes ces
demandes de différer des entreprises et
que nous avons également obtenu un point
très important nous avons vu avec la
banque de france que ses demandes
différait supplémentaire ne soit pas
considérée comme un défaut de paiement
des entreprises
normalement c'est le cas ça ne sera pas
le cas n'y aura aucune stigmatisation
d'une entreprise qui demande un délai
d'un an supplémentaire pour commencer le
remboursement
son prêt garanti par l'état ne voulons
pas que les entreprises soient gênés
dans le rebond qui est nécessaire nous
ajoutons à ces nouvelles modalités de
prêts garantis par l'état des prêts
directs
si jamais une entreprise n'a aucune
solution que les prêts garantis par
l'état ne conviennent pas qu'elle n'a
aucune possibilité d'accès de la
trésorerie nous accorderont des prêts
directs de l'état nous avons provisionné
un demi milliard d'euros à cette fin
ces prêts d'état pourront atteindre
jusqu'à 10000 euros pour les entreprises
de moins de dix salariés
cinquante mille euros pour les
entreprises de 10 à 50 salariés et au
delà de 50 salariés
l'état pourra accorder des avances
remboursables plafonné à 3 mois de
chiffre d'affaires
vous voyez qu avec ces nouveaux prêts
directs de l'état
il n'y a plus aucune raison qu'aucune
entreprise en france confronté aux
difficultés économiques ne trouve pas
une solution de trésorerie celle
engagements qui avaient été pris hier
par le président de la république il
sera tenu
enfin les loyers même si vous avez un
prêt garanti par l'état même si on vous
a annulé toutes vos charges sociales
même si vous disposez d'un fonds de
solidarité qui peut aller jusqu'à dix
mille euros
il reste les loyers qui sont parfois une
charge très important pour un
restaurateur pour un atelier pour un
fleuriste pour un indépendant
nous avons donc pris l'engagement de
régler la question des loyers cet
engagement là aussi va être tenu nous
introduirons dès le projet de loi de
finances pour 2021 un crédit d'impôt
incitant les bailleurs a annulé une
partie de leur loyer
cette mesure bénéficiera aux entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés choix si elles
sont fermées administrativement à cause
du confinement soit parce qu'elles
appartiennent au secteur de l'hôtellerie
des gaffes et de la restauration de la
culture que vous connaissez tous
bailleurs qui sur les trois mois
d'octobre novembre et décembre 2020
acceptent de renoncer au moins à un mois
de loyer sur les trois mois qui lui sont
dues pourra bénéficier d'un crédit
d'impôt de 30% du montant des loyers
abandonné qu'est ce que cela veut dire
concrètement
l'exemple d'un loyer mensuel de 5000
euros pour un restaurateur un
restaurateur important soit 15000 euros
sur trois mois si le bailleur renonce à
au moins un mois de loyer 5000 euros il
bénéficiera d'un crédit d'impôt de 1500
euros
qui donc rendre à cette charge moins
lourde pour lui le bailleur perdra donc
3500 euros au lieu de 5000 qu'il aurait
dû perdre avec cette remise
le restaurateur lui et c'est le point le
plus important père à 10000 euros de
loyer au lieu des quinze mille euros
qu'il aurait dû payer et l'état prendra
le reste à sa charge cela évitera aux
bailleurs de se retrouver confronté un
défaut de paiement ou à des impayés du
locataire et ça permettra aux
entreprises concernées de réduire de
manière très significative le montant de
leur loyer cela correspond exactement à
ce qui avait été demandé par lasser pme
et par un certain nombre d'entrepreneurs
je précise que cette aide sur les loyers
sera cumulable avec le fonds de
solidarité
elle sera cumulable nous évaluons la
dépense de l'état pour ce crédit d'impôt
à environ un milliard d'euros au total
enfin nous voulons toujours dans
l'objectif de soutenir massivement notre
économie accélérer la numérisation des
commerçants et des artisans puisque nous
voulons pour développer des dispositifs
de type click and collect durant le
confinement
ça suppose d'accélérer la numérisation
des entreprises elles ne sont que 32%
aujourd'hui parmi les plus petites
entreprises françaises a disposé leurs
propres sites internet
c'est trop peu nous apporterons des
moyens financiers pour permettre aux tpe
françaises d'accélérer leur numérisation
ça facilitera la vente à emporter les
livraisons à domicile
toutes ces initiatives qui sont prises
aujourd'hui par un certain nombre de
commerçants et que je tiens à saluer
parce qu'elles vont dans le bon sens et
j'incite tous nos compatriotes avoir des
comportements économiques patriotique à
soutenir ces initiatives des plus
petites entreprises et des commerces
parce que ça les aidera dans ces moments
difficiles je tiens à préciser que pour
les concessions automobiles et donc
derrière pour l'industrie automobile qui
est si vitale pour notre pays
les clients pourront venir chercher
leurs nouveaux véhicules sur rendez vous
quel est le coût total de ces mesures
toutes ces mesures représentent un coût
que nous évaluons à 15 milliards d'euros
par mois de confinement environ 6
milliards d'euros pour le fonds de
solidarité 7 milliards d'euros pour
l'activité partielle dont a parlé
lisabeth bornes un milliard d'euros pour
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
un milliard d'euros pour prendre en
charge une partie des loyers des
entreprises par souci de précaution
et comme nous l'avons toujours fait
depuis le début de cette crise et comme
l'indiqué le premier ministre à la
représentation nationale nous inscrirons
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année
une somme plus importante de 20
milliards d'euros pour nous permettre de
voir venir et d'anticiper d'éventuelles
difficultés supplémentaires
je tiens pour conclure ajouté deux
points importants pour garantir la
continuité de l'activité économique pour
le btp qui a été si important en mars
avril dernier lors du premier
confinement on nous avons de grandes
difficultés à maintenir des chantiers
ouverts
nous avons tiré les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé au printemps les protocoles
de sécurité sanitaire doivent être
appliquées comme l'indiqué le premier
ministre tous les magasins de matériaux
et d'outillage resteront ouverts y
compris d'ailleurs pour les particuliers
je pense à point p à leroy merlin à
bricorama conforama tous ces dispositifs
et tous ses magasins resteront ouverts
pour que le btp puisse fonctionner
j'insiste sur la nécessité que dans les
mairies des guichets reste ouvert pour
recueillir et accorder les demandes
permis de construire qui sont demandés
par le bâtiment et les travaux publics
car c'est absolument vital pour assurer
la continuité des chantiers enfin pour
tous les secteurs industriels
il est essentiel que les bureaux
d'études reste ouvert et que les
ingénieurs puissent s'y rendre pour le
secteur aéronautique pour le secteur
automobile
ces points là sont absolument
essentielles voilà les quelques éléments
que je voulais vous présenter je
voudrais terminer mes jeux prémunissent
par une conviction profonde
l'économie française a des bases solides
elle a des capacités de rebond
exceptionnel
nous avons rebondi au troisième
trimestre et nous avons rebondi
fortement
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à une
nouvelle épreuve sanitaire mais nous la
surmonterons nous surmonterons ces
conséquences du confinement nous
surmonterons cette épreuve sanitaires il
faut croire dans l'économie française
les puissantes elle est agile elle est
volontaire et de réussir merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre un secteur sera
malheureusement est fortement impacté
par les mesures prises pour endiguer
l'épidémie
c'est celui de la culture voilà pourquoi
nous allons aussi le soutenir et je
demande à la ministre de la culture
roselyne bachelot de me rejoindre et
pendant qu'elle arrive je précise que
les acteurs et l'économie du sport sont
également très touchés par nos
dispositions et qu'ils bénéficieront
d'un accompagnement spécifique
madame le ministre d'abord je veux dire
que nous pensons tous aux artistes aux
auteurs aux techniciens aux
organisateurs d'événements et de
spectacles au cinéma aux commerces
culturels
j'ai changé depuis l'annnonce du
confinement avec beaucoup d'acteurs du
monde culturel
je sais quel coup de tonnerre représente
ce confinement d'autant plus cruel
qu'ils avaient fait des efforts
colossaux pour s'adapter au couvre feu
la culture c'est de l'émotion c'est de
l'amour et c'est aussi un secteur
économique puissant qui va être
bouleversée dans les semaines qui
viennent
après avoir déjà beaucoup souffert le
président de la république le premier
ministre et le gouvernement depuis de le
début de la crise montré qu'ils étaient
mobilisés pour soutenir le monde de la
culture par des mesures sans précédent
et sans équivalent dans le monde et nous
continuerons à l'accompagner autant que
de besoin
il est essentiel de rappeler que les
mesures transversales qui ont viennent
d'être présentés par bruno le maire
élisabeth bornes bénéficie à la culture
massivement on pense à l'activité
partielle aux exonérations de charges ou
fonds de solidarité notamment à l'aide
aux loyers mais nous allons être
attentifs à toutes les situations
des mesures spécifiques complémentaires
seront mises en place pour tous ceux qui
ne seraient pas concernés par les
mesures transversales
la plupart de nos établissements publics
et de nos services à compétence
nationale seront fermées comme de façon
générale tous les lieux culturels qui
reçoivent du public salle de spectacles
musées à part les parcs patrimoniaux
c'est une décision très difficile mais
indispensable pour contenir le virus
il est aujourd'hui essentiel de
restreindre les déplacements et les
interactions en présentiel certaines
activités professionnelles peuvent
continuer dès lors qu'il n'y a pas de
public comme l'a annoncé le premier
ministre
concrètement la création artistique
continue de vivre les tournages les
répétitions de spectacles à huit clos
les enregistrements et captation des
oeuvres sans public sont tout à fait
possibles
les préparations d'exposition la
politique de prêt et d'acquisition des
musées le seront également
les chantiers les opérations de
restauration de travaux essentiels pour
notre patrimoine pourront se poursuivre
comme la dernière fois les marchands de
journaux restaurants ouverts
un exemple hippolyte et aricie qui
devait être créé à la mi novembre à
l'opéra comique sera programmé à la
télévision ce spectacle va donc trouver
son public
différemment cela veut dire aussi qu'à
l'issue de cette période de confinement
des spectacles seront prêts à être
programmés ou à reprendre immédiatement
c'est fondamental
concernant les librairies elles ne font
pas pour le moment partie des commerces
ouverts
mais elles pourront comme les disquaires
d'ailleurs organiser des activités de
livraison et de retrait de commandes
c'est-à-dire le
quand collecte et bien entendu les aide
à la numérisation dont on vient de
parler bruno le maire leur seront
appliquées
il est également prévu que les
bibliothèques puisse instaurer un
système de livraison sur place nous
verrons dans quinze jours au regard de
la situation sanitaire si une ouverture
classique redevient possible
les cours dispensés dans nos
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
de la culture le seront à distance les
modalités de maintien des travaux
pratiques des ateliers dans le strict
respect des conditions sanitaires
doivent encore être précisées lors du
premier confinement du printemps le
ministère avait mis en place le portail
culture chez nous accessible au grand
public depuis le site internet du
ministère nous réactivons cette
plateforme numérique
le ministère se mobilisent pour recenser
toutes les offres numériques qui seront
mises en place par nos opérateurs et les
acteurs culturels en lien avec les
directions générales régionales pardon
de l'action culturelle
l'etat sera au rendez vous depuis le
début de la crise l'état a été
massivement aux côtés de nos activités
culturelles il va continuer à le faire
merci merci mes chers concitoyens ce
nouveau confinement a pour objectif
central de vous protéger et de préserver
notre système sanitaire soumis à une
immense pression nous nous fixons un
objectif absolu accueillir tous les
malades soignés tous ceux qui en ont
besoin
ne laissez personne sans prise en charge
cela passe une nouvelle fois par un
effort exceptionnel de mobilisation des
professionnels de santé et
d'organisations de nos établissements et
je les salue ici une nouvelle fois
olivier ferrand ministre chargé de la
santé va vous en présenter les modalités
ce premier ministre il a plusieurs
objectifs quand on parle de la
préparation du système des sanitaires
le premier objectif le président de la
république l'a dit hier c'est la
préparation de nos hôpitaux pour être
capable d'accueillir et de soigner dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
un grand nombre de malades qui affluent
chaque jour dans nos hôpitaux
aujourd'hui encore au cours des 24
dernières heures ce sont plus de 2500
patients qui ont été admis à l'hôpital
et près de 400 patients dans le service
de réanimation alors comment est ce que
nous faisons d'abord nous augmentons le
nombre de lits qui sont destinés à
soigner des malades atteints du coc vide
dans l'ensemble du parc hospitalier
c'est-à-dire dans le parc hospitalier
public et privé cela ne se fait pas de
façon automatique et c'est un effort du
quotidien pour l'ensemble des équipes
des établissements de santé concernés
par exemple je pense à clermont ferrand
je pense au puy-en-velay je pense à
angers ou délit classiquement dédiées à
d'autres types de prise en charge sont
désormais dédiés à des malades du cobp
idées parfois même transformé dans des
soins critiques des soins intensifs pour
iliad m des malades qui sont en état
grave
par ailleurs nous augmentons également
le nombre de lits de réanimation nous
avions ouvert si 1400 lits en date
d'hier est en fait le nombre de lits
augmente au fur et à mesure que les
besoins augmentent puisque pour
augmenter les lits de réanimation c'est
comme pendant la première vague
il faut pouvoir libérer de la place dans
les réanimations c'est à dire des
programmes et des soins qui ne peuvent
donc plus bénéficier aux malades qui
n'ont pas forcément le coronavirus par
ailleurs 40 évacuations sanitaires ont
déjà eu lieu
des régions les plus soumises à la
contrainte solitaire je pense à la
région aura à la région occitanie à
destination des régions dans lesquelles
la pression salutaire est encore un peu
plus faibles je pense notamment à la
bretagne est la nouvelle aquitaine cette
solidarité entre les régions permet
d'éviter une saturation rapide des
réanimations dans nos hôpitaux
mais ce premier ministre j'ai déclencher
le plan blanc nationale qui vise à
demander aux agences régionales de santé
sur tout le territoire d'amorcer une
déprogrammation qui est proportionnée à
la situation sanitaire
dans chaque territoire et qui conduit
donc à repousser un certain nombre de
soins de médecine ou de chirurgie nous
faisons le choix de privilégier et de
maintenir autant que possible les prises
en charge pour les maladies chroniques
pour les cancers les activités de
greffes les soins aux personnes
atteintes de handicap et également pour
les troubles psychologiques et les
troubles psychiques dont on sait
d'ailleurs que la période du confinement
peut aggraver un certain nombre de deux
situations
par ailleurs nous avons besoin de
ressources humaines de personnel de
soignants supplémentaire c'est le plus
grand défi quand on veut augmenter les
capacités d'accueil à l'hôpital est en
réanimation pour cela au cours de l'été
nous avons formé plus de 7000 soignants
aux techniques de réanimation et de
prise en charge des malades atteints du
coc vide
par ailleurs nous pouvons compter sur
plus de 9000 soignants qui se sont déjà
inscrits sur les plateformes renfort
qu'ovide de manière à les prêter main
forte malgré la fatigue malgré la
distance malgré la pression au quotidien
jour et nuit aux équipes qui subissent
la vague de plein fouet
nous mobilisons aussi les étudiants en
santé les étudiants en santé sont
précieux ils le sont depuis le début de
l'épidémie et je tiens à les remercier
je tiens à remercier également les
doyens les universités les chu les qui
ont permis de libérer des étudiants en
santé quelle que soit la nature de ces
études de santé qui sont une aide de
tous les instants en ville comme à
l'hôpital
par ailleurs la médecine de ville est
aussi fortement mobilisée ce n'est plus
comme la première vague nous ne
demandons plus aux patients d'appeler le
samu et d'aller directement à l'hôpital
s'ils sont malades nous leur demandons
d'aller contacter leur médecin
on rétablit toutes les dérogations qui
était en cours au cours de la première
vague épidémique jusqu'à la consultation
téléphonique là où ça fait sens et nous
pouvons compter sur une mobilisation de
tous les instants de la médecine de
ville des pharmacies qui font un gros
boulot mais également évidemment des
kinés des infirmiers je ne les cite pas
tous mais tous ont une place à part dans
le système de santé face à cette
épidémie et bientôt ces libéraux
pourront commencer à déployer les fameux
tests antigénique et participez
renforcer notre démarche de stratégie
diagnostique une démarche diagnostique
qui augmente semaine après semaine et je
remercie la filière biologie nous sommes
en train d'atteindre les deux millions
de tests pcr réaliser chaque semaine
nous y sommes presque
et cette montée en puissance nous permet
de diagnostiquer un nombre toujours plus
important de malades et donc de ne pas
laisser des personnes contagieuses sans
diagnostic nos soignants sont donc
extraordinaire en ville comme à
l'hôpital dans la durée même si c'est
dur le meilleur moyen de les remercier
c'est de faire attention à nous c'est de
faire attention aux autres aux voisins
aux personnes vulnérables et non
vulnérables
c'est de respecter les règles en vigueur
dans le confinement c'est d'éviter qu'un
grand nombre de malades affluent dans
les cabinets de ville et des mains
hôpitaux c'est être solidaires les uns
avec les autres dans cette période
difficile
merci beaucoup
le confinement
comme le président de la république l'a
indiqué hier soir est imposée jusqu'au
1er décembre
je dis bien 1er décembre nous referons
un point dans deux semaines pour évaluer
la situation
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens nous vivons une situation
hors du commun
je ne cesserai de répéter la solution
est entre les mains de chacun d'entre
nous adaptons nos comportements limitons
nos contacts respectant les gestes
barrière portant le masque même chez
nous protégeons nous protégeons les
autres la situation sera très difficile
dans les semaines à venir les services
hospitaliers vont être mis à rude
épreuve dans la gestion de cette crise
comme de toutes les autres crises qui
nous frappe
le gouvernement et les services de
l'état sont totalement mobilisés
je tiens à remercier les élus locaux et
les collectivités locales qui sont
également pleinement mobilisé aux côtés
de l'état
nous devons plus que jamais être soudés
dans cette épreuve et c'est ensemble que
j'en suis persuadé nous la surmonterons
je vous remercie et les ministres et moi
même nous tenons à votre disposition
mesdames et messieurs pour répondre à
vos questions
monsieur le premier ministre bonjour
allison tassin pour tf1 lci vous avez
évoqué les attestations
qu'en sera-t-il pour les mineurs voire
les enfants qui se rendront à l'école
par leurs propres moyens
faudra-t-il une attestation et si oui à
partir de quel âge nous avons également
évoqué les lycées avec une forme de
souplesse on le sait dans certains
lycées les classes sont très chargés
certains étaient favorables à des
classes en 2000 groupe avec des cours
une semaine sur deux y êtes-vous
favorable
et puis enfin
c'est que les agriculteurs peuvent
poursuivre leur activité qu'en est il
des pêcheurs merci merci autre question
bonjour hélène bonnet pour lci tf1 ma
première concerne question concerne la
tolérance que vous avez évoquées pour
les retours de vacances
faudra-t-il lors de ses déplacements de
retour fournir une attestation
spécifique en tout cas un justificatif
pour prouver qu'il s'agit bien d'un
retour de vacances autre question vous
parlez d'un point d'eau d'ici 15 jours
vous avez choisi de ne pas fermer les
écoles est ce que vous pourriez d'ici 15
jours si la situation si la courbe de
l'épidémie ne s'infléchit pas décidé
finalement de fermer les écoles et enfin
une question sur les déménagements est
ce qu'il va y avoir une tolérance
concernant ces déménagements merci je
prie méric aziza radio j vous avez été
accusée d'imprévoyance par l'opposition
face à cette seconde vague de la
pandémie
dans ce contexte le gouvernement et vous
même êtes vous en capacité de gérer ces
deux crises à la fois à savoir la crise
sanitaire et la menace terroriste
en clair et de vous en mesure de
protéger les français sur ces deux
fronts et puis dans la mesure où
l'attend à donner c'est consécutif à ce
qui ressemble à une fatwa du président
turc erdogan contre le président macron
la france et charlie hebdo
y voyez vous un lien de cause à effet
une dernière question et puis après on
répondra le lot et une masse pour bfm tv
j'ai trois petites questions tout
d'abord sur l'attestation 1h01 km est ce
que vous ne craignez pas que ça accentue
les inégalités pour ceux qui habitent à
moins d'un kilomètre d'un parent qui va
rester ouvert et pour les autres qui
habiteront plus loin et qu'ils pourront
pas en bénéficier
une question aussi sur cette attestation
cède désormais que le virus circule
beaucoup plus dans les lieux fermés
est-ce que priver les gens de
déplacement en tout cas de déplacement
très limité à une heure ne va pas
favoriser la contamination dans les
foyers j'ai une question également sur
pourquoi ne pas donner aux personnes
fragiles des masques ffp2 et enfin sur
ce confinement vous avez dit qu'on fait
un point dans dans 15 jours mais peut-on
imaginer qu'il va durer plus
de quatre semaines huit semaines 12
semaines jean françois delfraissy ce
matin parlait d'un couvre-feu pour noël
je remercie très bien merci beaucoup
donc je vais d'abord demandé oublier
éducation nationale de venir nous
rejoindre en profitent effectivement
merci pour votre question j'ai j'ai
parlé des agriculteurs vous l'avez
entendu effectivement j'aurais dû
ajouter les pêcheurs qui viennent
entendu pourront continuer à exercer
leur activité professionnelle
donc les attestations pour les mineurs
oui elles seront délivrés par les
établissements scolaires et s'agissant
en plus généralement de de vos questions
sur l'éducation et notamment sur les
lycées je laisse le choix à jean michel
blanquer de répondre merci monsieur le
premier ministre
s'agissant de dellys et j'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait de la souplesse
parce que dans le protocole que nous
avons prévu vous avez un protocole
sanitaire d'une pas autrement dit des
hypothèses 1 2 et 3 en fonction de la
situation
ce que nous déclenchons maintenant c'est
le sait le protocole 2 donc avec les
règles sanitaires que j'ai résumé tout à
l'heure et puis vous avez un protocole
dits pédagogiques c'est-à-dire la
continuité pédagogique
lorsque l'on ferme ce protocole nous
l'appliquons déjà puisque depuis le mois
de septembre il y à des établissements
qui ont eu à fermer
souvent pendant 15 jours ou trois
semaines ça consiste à avoir d'abord des
ressources nous avons enregistré des
centaines d'heures de cours
nous avons aussi modernisées
l'application du cned qui s'appelle ma
classe à la maison et donc nous avons
toute une série de ressources
demain d'ailleurs en ligne sur le site
qui s'appelle eduscol l'ensemble de ces
ressources seront exposées tout un
chacun pourra pour avoir en complément
de celles qui sont déjà là et donc cela
permet lorsque une classe ou un
établissement est fermé d' assurer cette
continuité pédagogique
la situation dans les lycées est très
différente d'un lycée à l'autre
vous avez des lycées où il n'est pas
souhaitée du tout de passer en demi
groupe soit parce que la densité n'est
pas forte
soit parce que les expériences qui ont
existé notamment enjoint de deux groupes
font que les acteurs ne le souhaite pas
dans d'autres lycées
la situation peut être différente c'est
pourquoi avec les chefs d'établissements
nous regardons les syndicats de chefs
d'établissement si nous regardons si il
y à des assouplissements nécessaire le
vous allez avoir le phénomène de
certains élèves qui ne viendront pas
pour des raisons de santé
pour d'autres d'autres raisons
donc il va y avoir de toutes façons une
diminution de la densité des classes
mais l'objectif c'est la continuité
pédagogique on ne veut pas qu'il y ait
une seule journée de classe perdu pour
nos élèves je voudrais ajouter si vous
le permettez monsieur le premier
ministre un point qui a trait aussi à
l'organisation de la semaine prochaine
c'est que nous avons prévu un hommage et
ça a un rapport aussi avec la question
de monsieur aziza nous avons prévu un
hommage à samuel pâtit bien entendu cet
hommage évidemment ses modalités évolué
du fait d'être des circonstances
sanitaires et donc elle cela consistera
en début de semaine en une minute de
silence
mais il ya aussi des activités
pédagogiques et éducatives qui sont
prévus et dont nous fixerons la manière
dont cela s'étale dans le temps
demain là aussi après avoir écouté les
organisations syndicales
voilà je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre je l'invite le miz
la santé à me rejoindre pendant ce temps
vous m'avez posé une question sur la
tolérance que j'ai évoquées pour pouvoir
rentrer de vacances ce week-end pas trop
de formalise une simple attestation sur
l'honneur certifient sur l'honneur que
j'étais en vacances à paimpol et que je
rentre à paris par exemple suffira
les déménagements seront aussi ça c'est
pas une tolérance autorisée sur
justificatif évidemment de l'entreprise
de déménagement
pendant cette période de confinement le
ministre va sans doute y revenir mais
notre position est très claire à ce
stade il a été décidé de faire un
confinement jusqu'au 1er décembre 1er
décembre et un point d'étape dans quinze
jours
sur la base de données sanitaires
transparente le ministre de la santé va
vous en dire davantage mais c'est ainsi
que nous allons fonctionner par ailleurs
je vous indique de façon plus générique
s'il vous permettait que là je ne
répondrai pas aux questions relatives à
l'attentât de nice le procureur de la
république procureur antiterroriste est
seul habilité à s'exprimer vous le savez
sur l' enquête est comme gelée dit tout
à l'heure il y aura un conseil de
défense
présidé par le chef de l'état demain
matin j'entends bien sûr monsieur toutes
les attaques notamment de l'opposition
sur l'imprévoyance et autres vous savez
je suis serein et tout à fait mobiliser
je vous invite simplement et nos
concitoyens le voit bien à regarder
parce que je ne porterai pas
d'appréciation sur ma propre action ce
qui se passe dans les pays qui nous
entourent et je dis bien la plupart des
pays européens ont-ils empêcher une
deuxième bague et une deuxième vague
forte
non est-ce qu'ils ont été imprévoyant je
ne me permettrais pas de le dire recours
t-il à des mesures de la nature de
celles que nous prenons la réponse est
oui
ont-ils été imprévoyant ou inefficaces
je me garderai bien de porter une
appréciation sur leur action cette crise
sanitaire est extrêmement difficile
oui une deuxième vague était annoncé et
prévu ce qui nous a surpris
ce qui a surpris les scientifiques eux
mêmes en france comme ailleurs c'est sa
subite accélération dans les quinze
derniers jours
sans doute nous distille en raison de
considérations climatiques peut-être y
en at il d'autres
notre rôle notre mission c'est de nous
adapter aux conditions nouvelles et de
nous adapter
vite nous avions une stratégie qui a été
expliqué qui a été décrite le dernier
vecteur en a été le couvre feu
je vous avais dit ici même lors de notre
dernière conférence de presse un que
nous devrions attendre quelque temps
pour en apprécier des effets mais et je
suis sûr que vous vous en souvenez je
vous ai dit si au milieu de la semaine
prochaine c'était la semaine dernière
nous y sommes nous constatons une
dégradation très forte des indicateurs
sanitaires et c'est le cas alors il sera
de notre devoir d' amplifier notre
stratégie de lutte contre la crise
sanitaire
c'est ce que nous avons fait c'est la
décision qu'a prise le président de la
république monsieur le ministre je n'ai
pas grand chose à jeter mais ce prêt
ministre répond ce que vous avez apporté
à une question qui disait dont on peut
comprendre la logique c'est finalement
est-ce que
rester chez soi et ne pas aller s'aérer
dehors est ce que finalement ça va pas
augmenter la contagion si je résume la
question alors non tout là est tout
l'enjeu c'est le brassage
c'est à dire le nombre de rencontres je
rappelle très brièvement trois
paramètres dans une épidémie
la contagiosité du virus est à dire quel
est le risque que le virus se transmet
d'une personne à une autre
on peut pas agir dessus la durée pendant
laquelle un virus est contagieux
quand on l'a attrapée on ne peut pas
agir dessus et le nom de personne qu'on
peut contaminer
si on est contagieux et là on peut agir
dessus des gestes barrières dans du
masque la distanciation sociales
jusqu'aux confinement ont plus on réduit
le brassage à dire - envoi de gens
différents en une journée
et bien moi on a de risques de
transmettre le virus à d'autres
personnes
et c'est exponentiel donc rester chez
soi en dehors des activités type travail
éducation et puis une sortie courte tous
les jours ça permet d'éviter de croiser
davantage de personnes que ce soit dans
la sphère privée dans la sphère
professionnelle
c'est vraiment l'enjeu c'est à dire
c'est ce qui a marché au printemps
dernier c'est ainsi qu'on avait réussi à
réduire l'épidémie et a sauvé beaucoup
de vies beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de 10
et c'est ce que nous voulons faire avec
ce nouveau confinement une autre
question rapide c'était sur les masques
faut-il donner des masques ffp2 aux
vulnérables alors les recommandations
qu'on a des sociétés savantes c'est
qu'un masque chirurgical est conseillé
recommandé pour des gens qui sont
porteurs de maladies particulières et
donc ils ont des masques chirurgicaux
qui peuvent d'ailleurs leur être
prescrits et qui peuvent aller chercher
en pharmacie et donc ils n'ont pas une
recommandation de port de masques grand
public mais de masque chirurgical qui
est suffisant le masque ffp2 c'est quand
on est sûr quand on est vraiment exposés
à des projections importante abondante
en provenance de personne malade donc
c'est des soins particuliers dans des
milieux particuliers que par exemple de
réanimation ou dans certains services
d'urgence quand on va faire des
aspirations trachéale chez des patients
qui ont qui sont malades ou les
dentistes par exemple parce que vous
avez beau forcément beaucoup de
projections et puis sur la durée du
conflit dont vous avez répondu monsieur
le premier ministre sachant qu'on on
regardera dans les prochains jours ça va
commencer cette nuit on regardera il
faut pas attendre samedi dimanche ou
lundi une baisse de la courbe pendant le
confinement au printemps
il a fallu quand même attendre quelques
jours un peu moins d'une semaine pour
commencer à avoir un impact sur
l'incident c'est à dire le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations et il a fallu
dix-huit jours pour avoir un impact sur
la charge de soins à l'hôpital le nombre
de malades qui affluent à l'hôpital est
en réanimation puis qu'on le répète à
chaque fois ci je me contaminer
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas demain
que j'irai en réanimation si je dois y
aller ce sera dans dix à quinze jours
donc il faut un peu de patience et à
partir de là ça nous donnera des
indications à savoir est-ce que ça
baisse vite
ou est-ce que ça pèse pas suffisamment
vite et plus avec vite et bien moins
longtemps durera le confinement et donc
moi je ne peux absolument pas vous dire
et personne ne peut vous dire au fond si
quatre cinq six semaines c'est le bon
timing pour arriver à un objectif qui
est l'objectif du président la
république qui est moins de cinq mille
malades par jour à peu près pour
retrouver le contrôle de l'épidémie mais
nous pouvons si nous sommes solidaires
et pleinement acteur dans ce confinement
nous pouvons réussir à faire baisser
rapidement le nombre de cas et donc nous
pouvons avoir des espoirs d'y arriver
plus vite que les prévisions des
professeurs de précis sachant je le
précise que nous testons toujours plus
ce qui a un effet mécanique de faire
monter le taux d'incidence puisque qui
cherche trouve
j'en profite à la suite de ce qu'a dit
le ministre de la santé concernant les
masques pour rappeler à tout le monde
que les personnes vulnérables
particulièrement vulnérables à cette
maladie soit raison de leur âge soit à
raison d'un certain nombre de pathologie
dont elle souffre type le diabète
peuvent demander à leur médecin de se
faire prescrire des masques chirurgicaux
en pharmacie qui seront donc pour elle
totalement gratuit c'est un dispositif
qui existe depuis plusieurs semaines
mais je rappelle que son utilisation est
toujours possible on va prendre encore
s'ils voulaient bien quelques questions
bonjour en bourse france télévisions
concernant la question de
l'acceptabilité vous avez appelé les
français est soudé dans cette épreuve
comment allez vous les faire adhérer à
ce nouveau confinement et puis sur le
télétravail
madame bornes vous dit ce n'est pas une
option il y avait
les discussions en cours entre les
partenaires sociaux à ce sujet
maintenant que c'est plus une option est
ce que ça remet en cause ces discussions
qu en est il merci monsieur le ministre
pour l' agence france-presse
certains font état d'une perte du pib de
40 milliards d'euros pour us au mois de
novembre
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut déjà
imaginé un nouveau plan de relance
français et un nouveau plan de relance
européen puisque vous l'avez dit mes
voisins européens sont touchés de la
même manière dans sanitairement
qu'économiquement
bonsoir oui paco pour france info deux
trois petites questions pour atteindre
dix mille lits en réanimation comme l'a
annoncé le président de la république
hier soir ça va passer uniquement par
des programmations et y avoir des
créations de lignes et avec quel
personnel des précisions aussi sur
l'allègement des effectifs au collège et
lycée pourquoi pas imposer un
fonctionnement en demi groupe
enfin cinq jours de télétravail sur cinq
aux entreprises qui le qui peuvent se le
permettre est ce que c'est une
recommandation ou obligatoire si c'est
une recommandation peut-on parler dans
ce cas d'insomnie confinement je
remercie parfait bon ça m'a surpris
qu'honoré sur la moto l'agencé de brl
alors on se parle les attestations de
déplacements ne sont toujours pas
disponibles sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur
quand on se rend sur le site du
gouvernement il était indiqué que celle
ci serait disponible seulement à partir
de demain
est ce qu'il y aura donc une tolérance
pour celles et ceux qui devront se
rendre au travail demain matin merci à
l'est la dernière et puis je réponds
bonjour monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames les ministres messieurs les
ministres tardif pour ces newscan al
plus je vais me permettre de rebondir
sur la question de ma consoeur de bfm tv
concernant
les chiffres de l'épidémie vos
estimations on sait que durant la
première vague épidémique il a fallu au
moins trois semaines pour avoir et bien
les premiers signes concernant une
décrue du nombre de nouveaux cas du
nombre d'hospitalisations donc à
l'hôpital et du nombre d'hospitaliser en
service de réanimation pensez vous
concrètement que l'on puisse face à une
seconde vague pour reprendre vos propos
plus dur plus violente faire mieux que
lors de la première vague et penser à un
déconfinement à partir de quatre
semaines
ou est ce une question finalement
d'acceptabilité de ne partir que de
quatre semaines en quatre semaines afin
de faire comprendre à la population
et bien que finalement on peut on peut
restreindre et freiner l'épidémie en
assez peu de temps merci beaucoup
bien on va répondre je vais demander aux
mises à santé de venir me rejoindre et à
madame bornes de se préparer derrière
puisqu'il ya eu deux questions sur le
télétravail
la première question concernait le fait
de savoir si les français seraient sous
des danses est vraiment je le crois
profondément jeu je lis j'entends des
polémiques sommes en france faut les
accepter mais je crois avant tout au bon
sens de nos concitoyens les françaises
et les français depuis plusieurs mois
sont très inquiets fatigué exténué même
par cette crise et je comprends tout à
fait mais il ne se trompe pas d'ennemis
l'ennemi c'est le virus et ils savent
bien finalement que les mesures que nous
prenons qui je le répète sont à peu près
celle que prennent les pays comparables
au nôtre confronté hélas au même
phénomène que ces mesures sont
nécessaires je pense qu'ils vont se dire
que ce qu'a annoncé hier soir le
président de la république c'est à dire
un confinement adapté c'est à dire
tirant les leçons du premier confinement
est une décision indispensable compte
tenu de la situation du pays en tout cas
nous ne ferons rien en ce qui nous
concerne pour les diviser nous ferons
tout pour les accompagner pour prendre
sur terrain social sur le terrain
économique c'était un sanitaire bien sûr
est d'abord ce terrain éducatif toutes
les mesures de nature à la fois à les
rassurer
alors expliqué que nous faisons tout ce
qui est en notre pouvoir
sauf sans doute prévoir l'imprévisible
et cette épidémie a un côté un peu
imprévisible mais que nous faisons tout
ce qui est en notre pouvoir sans mégoter
à la fois pour les protéger et pour les
accompagner dans cette épreuve
j'ai dit au parlement aujourd'hui que le
rôle de l'état s'était d'abord dans ces
circonstances du protégé de soigner
d'être aux côtés de ceux qui souffrent
on a vu beaucoup tout à l'heure
deux secteurs d'activités qui vont
souffrir qui souffre déjà de cette crise
je pense aussi à des populations
particulières les jeunes les
indépendants monsieur le maire il ya
fait allusion à plusieurs reprises dans
son intervention ce qu'on appelle les
travailleurs de la deuxième ligne sujets
que nous avons commencé largement
abordée dans le cadre des conférences du
dialogue social les populations fragiles
précaires à l'égard desquels sans doute
il nous faudra aussi adapter nos
dispositifs
c'est le rôle de l'état le président de
la république l'a rappelé monsieur
verrons
deux questions ont été posées la
première comment est ce qu'on arrive à
dix mille lits de réanimation
d'abord le 15 avril dernier nous sommes
montés à 10700 lits de réanimation
donc nous l'avons fait et quand je dis
nous c'est pas le gouvernement
c'est l'ensemble du monde hospitalier
des agences régionales de santé qui ont
réussi comment est ce qu ils l'ont fait
son parti de 5000 ils sont montés à
10700 45 % de l'augmentation du nombre
de lits vient de la transformation de
lits de soins continus et de soins
intensifs en lits de réanimation
un gros tiers est venue de la capacité à
transformer des salles de bloc
opératoire ou des salles de réveil en
salle de réanimation ça veut dire que ça
impliquait une forte des programmations
des autres soins c'est ainsi qu'ils ont
réussi à le faire nous avons gardé une
augmentation de 15% pérenne des lits de
réanimation c'est à dire un nombre de
lits drea armée équipée qui ne s'est pas
réduit pendant l'été donc l'augmentation
du nombre de lits sera réalisé à mesure
que la situation sanitaire l'exigera par
ailleurs il ya quand même un changement
important entre la première et la
deuxième vague en terme de prise en
charge traitement on un tube - les
malades c'est à dire que les
anesthésistes réanimateurs les
réanimateurs ont moins besoin de mettre
un tube pour aider les patients à
respirer de les placer en coma
grâce à une technique qu'on appelle look
cyclo c'est de l'oxygène à 50 litres qui
en continu et qui permet d'éviter des
accusations et donc ce type de prise en
charge peut se faire dans des lits qui
sont peut-être moins armé que des lits
de réanimation emprunte tout cela nous
permet d'avoir une meilleure prise en
charge encore qu'au cours de la première
vague deuxième question est ce qu'on
peut faire mieux sans si j'ai bien
compris votre question est ce que on est
ce qu est ce qu on peut faire mieux
entre guillemets avec la première vague
où on avait confiné plus longtemps que
quatre semaines et pourquoi est ce qu'on
y arriverait cette fois ci en quatre
semaines je vous le dis et le premier
ministre l'a dit on ne dit pas quand
quatre semaines on est sûr d'y arriver
il ya aussi une différence avec la
première vague qui est importante
le virus va moins vite il va moins vite
pendant la première vague le nombre de
malades faisaient plus que doubler
parfois même ils pouvaient triplé en une
semaine
aujourd'hui le nombre de malades en
france il augmente
mais il augmente de l'ordre deux fois
deux ans dix à quinze jours
d'ailleurs chez certains de nos voisins
le virus va beaucoup plus vite chez nos
voisins allemands ils doublent en une
semaine chez les voisins italiens il a
fait x 10 en trois semaines ça va moins
vite en france pourquoi c'est pas parce
que le virus serait différent c'est
parce que les mesures de gestion
probablement les mesures de gestion les
mesures prises pour freiner la
circulation du virus souvenez vous de
marseille
d'autres métropoles avec des mesures
précoces qui ont été mises en place qui
ont permis d'avoir un effet et puis
l'effet du couvre-feu que nous ne
mesurons pas encore et dont nous
espérons aussi qui permettra de
renforcer l'action déterminée des
pouvoirs publics pour freiner ce virus
donc on verra si ça suffit ou non ce qui
est sûr c'est que plus on respecte le
confinement et plus on se serre les
coudes comme adil prison la république
hier soir à juste titre que l'on est
solidaire les uns vis-à-vis des autres
et qu'on est patient même si c'est dur
même si on en a marre plus on respecte
sa plus court ce sera
merci beaucoup les questions sur le
télétravail merci monsieur le premier
ministre
alors quand j'ai dit que le télétravail
n'est pas une option ce que j'ai voulu
dire c'est que la règle que j'ai énoncé
à savoir toutes les activités qui
peuvent être faites à distance doivent
être télétravail et ça n'est pas au
choix
c'est ce qui doit se mettre en oeuvre
dans toutes les entreprises et pour
donner de la force à cette règle nous
allons l'inscrire dans le protocole
national qui est en consultation auprès
des partenaires sociaux qui était en
consultation jusqu'à 17h et donc qui
sera mis en ligne ce soir et quand on
inscrit une règle dans ce protocole ça
devient la traduction concrète de
l'obligation de l'employeur d'assurer la
sécurité la santé des salariés donc
c'est vraiment une règle qui s'impose à
tous ensuite les métiers sont très
différents certains ne sont pas du tout
et les travaillable doute le sont
partiellement et certains le sont à 100%
et dans ce cas là ça peut conduire
effectivement ça va conduire dans la
période de confinement à télétravailler
à être en télétravail cinq jours sur
cinq ce qui moi j'ai des retours
effectivement ce n'est pas la position
de base des partenaires sociaux
je partage leur position en temps normal
ça n'est pas formidable de travailler
cinq jours sur cinq il ya des enjeux de
cohésion d'équipé des enjeux d'isolement
10 salariés
mais là dans la période particulière que
l'on connaît du confinement
oui il faut aller dans ce cas jusqu'à
cinq jours sur cinq est par ailleurs
c'est distincts des négociations que les
partenaires sociaux ont engagé pour
définir un cadre national sur le
télétravail qui doit par exemple
discuter des règles sur le volontariat
double volontariat celui de l'employeur
et du salarié pour passer en télétravail
là ça n'est pas le sujet du moment où la
réversibilité ça n'est pas non plus le
sujet du moment et je sais que les
partenaires sociaux qui ont une séance
de négociations le 3 novembre seront
attentifs à pouvoir avancer rapidement
sur cet accord sur lequel il discute qui
pourra donner des repères à toutes les
entreprises sur le télétravail
je pense que c'est effectivement
important d'avancer rapidement sur ce
sujet merci il y à une question sur le
fonctionnement des établissements
scolaires qui concerne dont jean michel
blanquer
c'est un protocole qui limite totalement
comme vous l'avez vu aussi le l'objectif
c'est de distinguer écoles collèges et
lycées puisque on doit distinguer en
fonction de l'âge
tout semble montrer que plus un enfant
est petit - il est contaminants le sujet
se pose donc en des termes différents au
collège et au lycée
d'abord parce qu'au collège de manière
naturelle il ya moins de brassage parce
que moins d'options moins de
déplacements des élèves que
classiquement il ya souvent aussi moins
de densité au collège il faut aussi
avoir à l'esprit que lorsqu'en juin
nous avons créé des deux groupes est que
lorsque dès le mois de mai nous avions
un protocole sanitaire extrêmement
strictes souvenez-vous de des critiques
que nous entendions aussi des
difficultés concrètes que cela posait et
que nous aurions inévitablement quel que
soit le degré de préparation de chaque
établissement
donc il ne faut pas sous-estimer les
problèmes que pose le fait d'organiser
en demi-groupe donc la situation est
différente en collège et en lycée et
nous devons prévoir de la souplesse
notamment pour les lycées pour qu'ils
puissent s'organiser de leur façon
toutes les enquêtes que nous faisons
auprès des lycées montrent que les
situations sont différentes jeffrey
notamment une distinction entre les
lycées professionnels
d'une part et les lycées généraux et
technologiques d'autre part nous savons
qu'il ya des risques de décrochage plus
fort en lycée professionnel et que aussi
la densité est généralement plus faible
en lycée professionnel
c'est typiquement le cas où il n'est
vraiment pas souhaitable de créer des
demies groupe sauf sauf exception
quant au lycée général et technologique
on doit être pragmatique en fonction de
ce qui se réalise dans chaque lycée mais
une autre option n'est pas d'encourager
les demies groupe parce qu'encore une
fois nous voulons que les élèves a
fortiori ceux qui ont des examens de fin
d'année puissent ne pas avoir
d'interruption ou de gêne dans dans
leurs études très bien il y avait pardon
une question sur l'économie et la
relance
monsieur le ministre
et juste pour bien préciser les chiffres
nous avons vu lors du premier
confinement une chute d'activité de 30%
notamment en raison de l'effondrement du
btp et de la quasi fermeture des
chantiers
nous visons cette fois avec toutes les
dispositions que nous avons prise avec
les mesures de soutien avec les mesures
d'accompagnement de simplification en
particulier pour le bâtiment et travaux
publics
nous visons un ralentissement de
l'activité moitié moindre de 15%
donc ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a
confirmé que nous ne pouvons pas
poursuivre l'activité économique dans
des conditions de sécurité sanitaire qui
ont été rappelés par le premier ministre
je tiens également à dire sur la relance
que nous voulons continuer à avancer en
protégeant les entreprises qui doivent
être protégés je pense en particulier
aux indépendants plus petites
entreprises de secteurs qui sont les
plus touchés à tous les commerces qui
ont été fermés tout en engageant sans
délai la relance tout ça est affaire de
curseur dans la période nous sommes
aujourd'hui il y à une crise sanitaire
il ya des fermetures de commerces donc
nous allons pousser le curseur de la
protection des entreprises et nous
poussons comme je crois ne leur ont dit
clairement au maximum parce que c'est
notre responsabilité c'est notre
stratégie depuis le premier jour de la
crise sanitaire ne changeront pas de
stratégie mais ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il ne faut pas engager la
relance économique dont dépendra le
rebond de 2021 et la sortie de la crise
en 2022
enfin sur la relance européenne comme je
voulais dit j'ai appelé les homologues
européens dans la journée notamment le
président de l'eurogroupe et nous
souhaitons que le plan de relance
européen soit maintenant adopter sans
délai c'est justement parce que la crise
sanitaire s'aggrave dans certains pays
européens qu'il ya des difficultés
économiques que le plan de relance
européen d'être adoptée sans délai et de
lançons un appel en ce sens de la
semaine prochaine merci monsieur le
ministre je termine cette conférence de
presse en vous indiquant qu' on me
précise que l'attestation devrait être
téléchargeable entre 20h30 et
21h sur le site point gouv.fr je vous
remercie de votre attention et je vous
dis à très bientôt parce que bien
entendu nous en toute transparence vous
tiendrons très régulièrement informé de
l'évolution de la situation
merci beaucoup de figaro la ville est
très exactement et bien 20h02 nous
sommes en direct après et bien un peu
plus d'une heure et demie de conférence
de presse de la part des membres du
gouvernement nous venons d'entendre jean
castex le premier ministre bien
évidemment jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation elisabeth
bornes la ministre du travail bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie
roselyne bachelot la ministre de la
culture et bien sûr olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
nous sommes bien ensemble encore pour un
petit moment pour revenir et bien en
résumé sur les différentes annonces qui
ont été faites de la part du
gouvernement mais également revenir plus
en détail sur un point qui semblait bien
je vous intéresser particulièrement
notamment sur youtube
surtout ce qui va être éducation avec et
bien ce qui a pu se dire en terme est
bien de prépa 2
d'enseignement supérieur de lycées de
reprise des cours on le sait que tout
les taux les établissements ne seront
pas fermées bien au contraire on va voir
un petit peu comment cela se passe avec
sophie de tarlé rédactrice en chef au
figaro étudiant que je suis mère en
train de contacter ici même n'hésitez
pas à poser toutes vos questions à
réagir dans le tchat
on essayera de prendre toutes vos
questions merci en tout cas à vous qui
nous suivait sur bien la page twitter du
figaro merci à théo 512 wallisch ses
docks salle valoches n'en valait cheval
icher bien cela nerf de la guerre que
j'ai pu suivre vous rejetez vont jeter
que j'ai plaisir à retrouver bab sont
sûres twitch toujours merci sur la page
principale du figaro à brad pitt risques
et 22 pragma jean paul 2 bien évidemment
on attend 770 freeski et deux avec
respect vous êtes nombreux à nous suivre
enfin merci à vous sur les biens youtube
ou là vous êtes très nombreux et je
pourrai pas tous vous citez bien
évidemment mais on va quand même faire
une petite vague de salutation bonjour
d'art curie qui nous demande pour les
bts comme pur intérêt au tvb on va y
répondre en quelques secondes on nous
demande aussi pour les auto-écoles
l'apprentissage et bah écoutez on va on
va prendre tout de suite vos
commentaires avec sophie de tarlé que je
vais essayer de joindre ici même est-ce
que vous m'entendez sophie bonsoir alors
vous êtes vous avez suivi en même temps
que nous eh bien cette cette déclaration
qu'elles ont été bien les points
importants qui nous ont appris peut-être
un peu plus de choses ont apporté un peu
d'eau à nos moulins en ce qui concerne
l'éducation
alors ce qui concerne l'éducation
jean-michel lancker a parlé d'un
protocole sanitaire durci c'est ce sont
ses mots c'est vrai que il ya beaucoup
de gens ont réagi en disant que ça
ressemblait plus ou moins à celui que
l'on a connue il n'y avait pas d' énorme
différence donc
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas dire ce soit
une révolution donc je rappelle quand
même ces mesures c'est l'arrivée le
départ étalée dans le temps
le fait d'être une classe de rester dans
sa classe anna et de pas le changer de
classe à chaque fois qu'on change de
cours sur ce point d'ailleurs il ya
beaucoup de d'enseignants qui ont réagi
sur sur les réseaux sociaux en disant
que depuis justement depuis la réforme
du bac énoncé par jean michel blanquer
justement il n'ya pas de classe en 1ère
et terminale
puisque il ya plus de spécialité en fait
un lien plus e s scl comme avant donc ça
va être un peu compliqué justement il ya
ce brassage entre les spécialités
donc voila et puis sinon il y avait
l'idée de la création par petits groupes
d'organiser des récréations
éventuellement en classe pour éviter
toujours le brassage et puis une bonne
nouvelle le maintien de la cantine
c'était assez redouté donc là avec avec
l'idée de des sensations d'un mètre
entre chaque élève ce qui est à mon avis
sera assez difficile à respecter mais
bon c'est pas de ces pas non plus des
voilà des choses extrêmement nouvelles
ce qui était attendu par les enseignants
c'était le fait de faire des petits
cours des cours en petits groupes avec
une enseignement alternée par exemple
une semaine une semaine et là jean
michel blanquer rappaz n'a pas du tout
annoncer ça parce que l'objectif selon
lui c'est vraiment ne perde aucune
journée de cours donc de vraiment que
éviter en fait le décrochage scolaire et
et que les élèves à et tous en classe
donc ça c'est très important pour lui et
puis deuxième chose permettent aux
parents de travailler
c'est important de travailler ou de
télétravail et mais en tout cas de
vraiment de garder une scolarité normale
mais voilà donc c'est pas c'est parce
pas de grosses mesures protocole durci
bon on s'attendait à pire donc je pense
que là c'est tout à fait jouable on a
beaucoup de questions sophie en ce qui
concerne les études supérieures bien
évidemment on ne sait donc bien c'est
désormais par internet que vous de voir
ce passé-là prix là la priorité les
court
on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
questions ce qui concerne les bts pour
répondre à nos internautes sur sur
youtube notamment
est ce que vous pourriez revenir un
petit peu sur les mesures qui ont été
prises dans ce domaine particulier pour
répondre tous nos internautes
ouais c'est vrai que cette question est
important c'est à dire les bts mais
aussi les étudiants de classes
préparatoires puisque
c'est ces formations lorsqu'elles se
déroulent dans des dans des lycées la
question de savoir si puisque les lycées
sont ouverts est ce que ces formations
perdure j'avoue que je me suis tout de
suite évidemment posé la question je
mets à l'annonce du confinement on a
demandé aux ministères etc et sur
nationale et on n'a pas eu de réponse
donc je vais être un peu décevante sur
ce point moi ce que j'ai compris c'est
que lorsque les formations sont offertes
dans des lycées puisque les lycées sont
ouverts il n'y a pas de raison que c'est
que les formations ferme toutes les
formations qui sont dans des lycées je
crois que le lycée jean toutes les
classes préparatoires par exemple sont
dans des lycées
donc là pour il n'y a pas de raison que
ça ferme mais je vous dis j'ai aucune
confirmation de la part du ministère
l'éducation nationale c'est le cas pour
les bts après les bts qui sont dans des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
il y en a aussi
là ce sera des champs ce sens qu'elle
travaille alors à les distancer
on a énormément de questions en ce qui
concerne bien l'apprentissage en ce qui
concerne les certains à certaines
formations
est-ce que
est ce que en fait finalement en ce qui
concerne toutes les études supérieures
ça va dépendre que de l'ouverture des
établissements comme si tout ce qui est
lycée professionnel c'est à dire mais
aussi les cfa qui sont pas des lycées
professé professionnels j'entends bien
mais qui font qu'ils ont quand même le
même but
resteront ils me semblent ouverts par
exemple les écoles une école hôtelière
qui propose un diplôme de niveau c ap
bac pro et cetera et même si elle a le
statut de cfa il me semble qu alors
qu'elle restera ouvert on n'a pas de
précisions exact mais je me file un
petit peu à mon expérience des
précédents confinement et des précédents
de fermeture d'établissement en général
c'est ce qui est décidé puisque le but
c'est justement de permettre à ces
jeunes des lycées professionnels mais
par extension les cfa dont font parties
de poursuivre leur scolarité est
vraiment d'éviter le décrochage et comme
l'a rappelé le ministre
ggp a même bien entendu ça le risque de
décrochage scolaire est beaucoup plus
important dans tout l'enseignement
professionnel donc aucune raison que les
cfa on a aussi pas mal de questions en
ce qui concerne mais les stages c'est
que beaucoup de nos étudiants biens sont
en recherche ou avec des stages validé
on le sait aussi que beaucoup de stages
avaient sauté lors du premier
confinement est ce qu on est aussi dans
cette attente un petit peu d'information
est ce qu'on en a des plus précises non
alors pour les stages les stages peuvent
eux peuvent être réalisées bien sûr
après tout dépend de la politique de
l'entreprise
si c'est une entreprise où
où les bd des salariés sur place qui
peuvent accueillir l'éventuelle mans
c'était le stagiaire puisque là le
travail ne peut pas faire en télétravail
en bref il ya vraiment une une vie en
entreprise est bien le stagiaire viendra
en entreprise si le cil la règle est
dans l'entreprise et que le le travail
se fait à distance
on peut imaginer que le stagiaire peut
aussi faire son travail à distance
moi personnellement au figaro on a des
stagiaires de troisième qui viennent
c'est le cas c'est la question se pose
aussi pour ceux pour eux puisque
beaucoup viendront au mois de décembre
en tout cas cette année même si ce stage
n'est pas obligatoire en raison des
pourra être repousser éventuellement
mais disons que il peut éventuellement
si c'est possible de se faire à distance
aussi donc même si c'est évidemment
moins amusant et le jeune aura tout
intérêt à le repousser un peu plus tard
à mi mots bien un stage que tout à fait
se faire à distance après et aussi sur
place si c'est une entreprise
imaginons un stage dans une entreprise
de btp le chantier ne va pas s'arrêter
pour autant donc il peut faire son stage
si le sujet dans un bureau et que le
sait le télétravail et bien il peut
faire son stage à distance ce serait
bien d'ailleurs que les entreprises
jouent le jeu et il continue de prendre
des stagiaires et sort un bassin
concerne aussi le domaine de
l'alternance là on avait une question de
wilde gold 38 sur twitter qui nous dit
je suis alternant en tant que
développeur informatique peut-on refuser
le télétravail alors que l'autoroute pau
l'autorisent à d'autres salariés
ben ça ça dépend vraiment de votre
maître renard employeur on peut pas vous
refuser si vous avez la possibilité de
travailler vraiment votre travail peut
se faire à distance
on peut plus vous le refusez puisque
aujourd'hui comme comme la président
après précisé
les membres du gouvernement c'est la
règle le télétravail est aujourd'hui la
règle
donc il n'y a plus de raison a donné
enfin voila c pendant un mois j'ai en
tout cas juste qu'on a de décembre ce
sera la règle
et puis alors qu'avant oui en effet il y
avait eu des accords et c'était on
pouvait éventuellement refuser le
télétravail l'annoncé plus le cas et
puis comme l'a dit elisabeth bornes la
ministre du travail et bien
le télétravail c'est une obligation pas
une option
voilà en tout cas ce que nous a rappelé
la règle de la ministre du travail ce
soir on a aussi beaucoup de questions de
votre part sur youtube notamment sur les
auto écoles et ce qu'elles resteront
fermées bien en théorie oui les
auto-écoles et moto école reste bel et
bien fermées pour être allé passer j'ai
demandé moi dans une moto-école ce matin
et dans le noyau là et on m'a vraiment
dit que c'était fermé pendant toute la
durée du confinement
voilà pour pour ces informations on a on
a entendu durant la conférence de presse
mais il sera toujours possible de passer
le permis par contre aller les examens
eux sont sont maintenus oui j'ai bien
entendu ça d'accord et bien voilà qui
vous apporte des informations précieuses
notamment pour pour vous sûr sur youtube
au mm3 king donc tous les examens y
compris ceux du permis de conduire j'ai
bien entendu ça le les examens les
concours universitaires pourront se
faire en présentiel en respectant les
gestes l'arrière d'accord ah ben voilà
qui vous apporte un peu plus de 2
d'information merci à vous en tout cas
d'être avec nous sur youtube sur twitch
mais également sur la page principale du
figaro bonjour carreaux photographie
vous demander quelques questions sur les
commerces et sur la fermeture de
certains établissements on va arriver à
y revenir juste après ça on va continuer
on va finir de parler un petit peu de
tout ce qui va être éducation puisque
nous sommes avec sophie de tarlé
rédactrice en chef au figaro étudiant on
avait sophie aussi beaucoup de questions
en ce qui
les internats c'est vrai que les
internats leçon un régime un peu à part
dans l'eure dans leur fax sont façon de
fonctionner est-ce qu'on a plus
d'information là dessus
non on n'a aucune information mais rien
n'est rien n'a été dit sur les internats
et surtout il n'y a pas deux et on n'a
aucune information comme quoi ils
fermeraient donc pour moi il reste
ouvert les internats ils restent ouverts
comme comme tous les collèges lycées et
écoles primaires les crèches tous les
internats restent ouverts durant cette
période
je rappelle que c'est vraiment l'idée
c'est de que les élèves ne rate pas deux
heures de cours continuez le canton qui
continuent leur scolarité le mieux
possible et si on commence à fermer les
internats ça veut dire que ces élèves
n'auront pas cours du tout donc
donc ce n'est pas possible donc les
internats restera l'une des actualités
de la journée c'est aussi le port du
masque obligatoire désormais à partir de
6 ans à partir du cp est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est réalisable cette mesure
pour des tout petits
on peut le dire je pense que oui parce
que ils ont l'habitude de nous voir
c'est rentré dans les moeurs
honnêtement je pense que des enfants de
6 ans sont tout à fait capables de
garder leur masse
après si c'est pas un p4 pas non plus
très très grave puisque on sait que ils
sont pas ils sont pas vraiment très
contagieux donc c'est après c'est une
décision du conseil scientifique donc je
vais pas me je veux pas dire c'est pas
une mauvaise décision mais en tout cas
je pense que les enfants de 6 ans ils
sont tout à fait capables de garder un
match il le gens voient même souvent
dans la rue des enfants qui les portent
donc après est ce que c'est
c'est peut-être plus pour rassurer les
enseignants que les élèves en eux mêmes
puisque ne risque rien donc par contre
les enseignants à risque gros donc je
pense que c'est plus pour eux qu'on
n'oblige les enfants accablé le masque
est aussi ça fait partie des
informations qu'on a
on a eu en ce qui concerne les cours de
sport alors on a beaucoup beaucoup aussi
question là je crois qu'il ya vraiment
trois grands axes ce soir ce sont les
bts la prépa les auto écoles mais
également les cours de sport donc même
quatre points les cours de sport au
lycée sont ils maintenus c'est une bonne
question est en tout cas les sports que
ça n'a pas été précisé non plus après
tout les sports collectifs
on en a parlé ce soir sont plus
autorisés les salles de sport sans
fermer donc non il n'y a pas eu de
précisions sur le sport à l'école donc à
voir
je pense qu'il y aura de plus des
précisions sur ce point mais je sais pas
encore on va revenir peut-être une
dernière fois vous l'avait déjà expliqué
mais on a beaucoup d'internautes qui
nous ont rejoints entre temps notamment
sur youtube ce que vous pourriez une
refaire un dernier petit point en ce qui
concerne les bts et les prie pas pour
répondre à nos internautes inquiète et
ça c'est vraiment le l'une des grosses
tendances qu'on peut observer ce soir
dans le chat alors juste évidemment je
m'étais penché sur le sujet elle
rapidement on a demandé aux militants
une question nationale qui nous a pas
répondu
mais bon j'ai réécouté le discours et de
jean-michel bloqué et il est bien
précisé que les lycées restent ouverts
donc moi ce que j'ai compris c'est que
les classes qui qui sont organisées dans
des lycées si le bts par exemple dans un
lycée et que le lycée reste ouvert et
que l'enseignement se déroule
eh bien il n'y a pas de raison que ça
que ça ne se passe pas pareil pour les
bts
après s'il s'agit de d'établissements
d'enseignement supérieur dans ces cas là
l'enseignement se fera à distance je
pense que il faut le voir comme ça après
je n'ai aucune assurance on n'a toujours
pas la réponse en fait du ministère du
ministre donc c'est un petit peu et déjà
des lycées qui sont exprimés en disant
que ben ils continueront d'ouvrir je
crois que c'est lycée janson de sailly
qui a fait ça qui a précisé que ben ils
resteront et le garderont leurs cases le
pré pas ouverte mais mais bon pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien donc c'est
un petit peu mystère comme le ver ne
manquera pas en tout cas de suivre les
différentes actualités qui nous
parviennent avec vous et toute votre
équipe du figaro étudiant je vous
remercie beaucoup
demain de toute façon pour les prépas et
les bts mais uniquement ceux qui sont en
lice et un bien sûr je pense qu'on
pourra on sera susceptible de vous de
vous le dire demain champ de foot h
je pense que les ministres j'en sors un
peu plus à ce moment là eh bien merci
beaucoup sophie n'hésitez pas à
retrouver tous les articles de sophie et
de ses équipes en direct sur le figaro
étudiant
bah merci je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée sophie nous on va rester
ensemble encore quelques instants pour
revenir sur les différentes mesures qui
ont été annoncées ce soir par les
différents membres du gouvernement on va
bien consulter cela en direct
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions à
comme bien vous wallisch sur twitch qui
nous demandent si les transports en
commun reste fonctionnel et bien oui il
reste fonctionnel voilà on a pu répondre
en tout cas beaucoup de questions
d'entre vous sur les bts notamment pour
vous hakim sur twitch pour mathis
également sur les internats nous avons
bien arboré toute cette information
mais ce ne sont pas que des informations
de jean michel blanquer
la ministre de l'éducation qui nous sont
parvenus on va revenir là dessus pour le
moment bien
je vais déjà vous saluer avant de
commencer je vois encore beaucoup de
questions sur les auto écoles alors
sachez que les auto écoles sont fermées
mais que et bien techniquement les
examens eux peuvent être maintenus donc
si vous devez passer et bien des examens
du code de la route et bien ou de la
conduite en moto ou en voiture
n'hésitez pas à vous rapprocher de votre
auto écoles ou de votre moto école pour
avoir un peu plus d'informations voilà
en ce qui concerne les bts donc ils sont
bel et bien maintenu voilà j'essaie en
tout cas vous êtes très nombreux sur
youtube j'essaye de suivre le fil de vos
questions et vos commentaires si en tout
cas on rate un petit peu certains de vos
commentaires de vos questions comme vous
êtes très nombreux
n'hésitez pas à retrouver ce live à
henri plex soit sur le figaro sur la
page youtube du figaro mais également
sur twitter tout est disponible
on a commencé ce débrief à partir de 1h
36 donc comme ça vous avez le code
temporel vous n'avez plus qu'à vous y
rendre et vous aurez toutes les réponses
qui vous intéressent concernant
l'éducation bonsoir elle bulletti vous
nous demandez si on a des informations
concernant les plus précaires et bien on
va revenir là dessus
dans quelques minutes n'hésitez pas à
rester avec nous au passage merci à vous
pour le follow sur twitch vêtir et white
gold 38
je vous remercie on va prendre vos
questions avant cela on va faire un
petit point d'actualité sur les
différentes annonces qui ont été faites
ce soir pendant un peu plus d'une heure
et demie on a pu suivre cela en direct
sur figaro live est ce qu'on a appris
non qui est bien ce sont beaucoup de
choses tout d'abord je vais vous
répondre sur twitch et bien ce qui
concerne les différents commerces qui
ont été fermés c'est vous car aux
photographies qui nous demander quelles
sont les commerces nommé essentiel même
liste qu'en mars alors la liste est un
peu plus large qu'en mars
voilà si vous souhaitez en tout cas et
bien savoir sachez que les listes sont
disponibles sur internet
mais pour vous citer un exemple car le
panel est assez large est beaucoup plus
large que lors du premier confinement et
bien tous les commerces de bouche
que ce soit les boulangers les
poissonniers bouchers primeur pâtissier
caviste également tous et bien sûr les
toutes les supérettes les supermarchés
et les hypermarchés
les marchés de plein air sauf si le
maire refuse ou le préfet pour des
raisons de sécurité donc tout ce qui va
être alimentation générale est bel et
bien maintenu les blanchisseries les
laveries les pressings
on sait aussi que les parcs et jardins
resteront ouverts on l'a appris tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée nationale avec
jean castex le premier ministre tout
comme bien les cimetières les forêts et
plages elles sont ouvertes c'est une
différence qu'on avait pu observer lors
du premier confinement et en ce qui
concerne et bien la fonction publique et
les différents services qui sont
essentiels à notre société est bien pôle
emploi le guichet des impôts les
guichets de mairie tous les guichets en
fait reste ouvert on a également et bien
les agences d'intérim les bureaux de
poste qui reste ouvert les commissariats
les préfectures les banques et
assurances voilà je ne vais pas vous
faire l'ensemble de la liste car elle
serait longue
en tout cas en ce qui concerne les
commerces qui eux sont fermés et bien
les cafés bars restaurants bien
évidemment les fleuristes les salons de
coiffure si vous n'avez pas pu aller
chez le coiffeur avant cela et bien il
va falloir attendre au moins deux
semaines c'est ce que nous a appris jean
castex le premier ministre si ce n'est
un peu plus car bien dans deux semaines
ce sera seulement un point d'étape qui
nous a été annoncé par le premier
ministre et hier soir par les manuels
mâcon est donc bien peut-être que ce
sera jusqu'au 1er décembre date à
laquelle en tout cas ce confinement
numéro deux doit au minimum ce
ce perdurer voilà en ce qui concerne les
autres commerces fermés et bien on sait
les campings les musées les théâtres
sont fermés alors en ce qui concerne le
monde de la culture roselyne bachelot la
ministre de l'économie nous a fait un
petit point il nous a précisé que en ce
qui concernait les répétitions les
tournages et beaucoup d'événements du
monde de la culture est bien seraient
eux poursuivis voilà les tournages les
répétitions les enregistrements les
créations artistiques eux pourront se
poursuivre on le sert le monde de la
culture qui est lui aussi bien
particulièrement particulièrement
attaquées par ce parce par ce
confinement
on le sait le confinement va est bien
représenté plusieurs milliards de
dollars de pertes ce que nous a annoncé
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
voilà pour en tout cas ces dernières ces
informations voilà n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur internet si vous souhaitez
avoir un détail un peu plus précise et
des différents commerces qui sont fermés
voilà pour ces précisions alors je vois
votre question sur twitch hard rock qui
le dit bonsoir en ce qui concerne les
commerciaux en porte à porte c'est
toujours aussi floue bien c'est une
c'est une bonne question n'a pas eu de
précisions en ce qui concerne le
porte-à-porte j'en suis désolé mais
n'hésitez pas à nous retrouver pour les
prochains là il va reposer votre
question d'ici là on aura eu un peu plus
d'informations voilà pour cela merci à
vous en tout cas qui nous suivaient sur
twitch merci sur youtube vous vous êtes
toujours nombreux comme
ventre heures sofien alors ça défile
très vite j'ai beaucoup de mal à vous
suivre
extinction topping motivation majster
galy voilà vous êtes vous êtes très
nombreux
voilà on serre les restaurants qui
pourront malgré tout bien continuer de
livrer alors vous voit aussi encore
beaucoup de questions n'hésitez pas à
les poser je vais essayer d'en prendre
un maximum
on nous demande si les collèges sont
ouverts oui les collèges lycées sont
ouverts et sont maintenus voilà pour
vous répondre sur youtube
merci à vous qui est toujours avec nous
et que je n'ai peut-être pas salué
françois oth sur la page principale du
figaro merci de nous avoir rejoint de
nouveau je reconnais votre non merci
boris vins et vous pragma d'être avec
nous avec respect qui est toujours avec
nous également
voilà pour ses salutations et donc eh
bien ces annonces du gouvernement qui
ont été nombreuses ça va être dur de
vous faire un débrief assez concis et
exhaustif puisque eh bien ce ne sont pas
moi que sept membres du gouvernement qui
se sont qui se sont rassemblés ce soir
pour nous faire part des différentes
mesures qui ont été prises par leurs
gouvernements respectifs alors que l'on
apprend et bien une manifestation
sauvage contre le confinement a été
organisée ce jeudi soir à paris pour
protester donc content le confinement ce
sont des manifestants qui ont commencé
bien place de la république et qui se
sont dirigés vers la rue de rivoli pour
protester contre la politique d'
emmanuel macron va dites nous ce que
vous pensez ce que vous pensez de ce
confinement est ce que vous êtes plutôt
pour escales inverse
vous êtes contre nous n'hésitez pas à
nous le dire prendre à toutes vos tous
vos commentaires en direct sur figaro
live ce sera avec plaisir là je vois
encore beaucoup de questions en ce qui
concerne les bts et les prépas alors on
vous la dire ils sont bel et bien
maintenu en ce qui concerne ça
concernera plutôt votre établissement de
savoir si votre cours et en présentiel
ou pas aussi il se fait à distance voilà
on l'a appris donc
et bien que l'on retourné vers un
système d'attestation ces attestations
pourront être soit permanent si votre
employeur vous peut vous le donnez vous
si votre établissement scolaire peut
vous le livre et vous aurez donc une
attestation permanente et sinon et bien
les attestations devront être faits au
kilomètre et à l'heure et selon et bien
des raisons qui sont jugées essentielles
voilà qui qui nous apporte un peu plus
d'informations et si vous voulez
chercher ces attestations sachez
qu'elles seront disponibles entre 20h30
et 21h sur le site du gouvernement
donc voilà n'hésitez pas à les retrouver
on a appris également pas mal de choses
en ce qui concerne l'économie là on va
pas pouvoir faire exhaustif de nouveau
car bruno le maire avait beaucoup de
choses à nous dire on ne sait et bien il
va falloir prévoir un ralentissement de
l'activité et de 15 % contre 30 % au 1er
confinement ce qui est quand même bien à
prendre en compte
on a appris je vais essayer de vous
retrouver ces informations qu'un crédit
d'impôt pour les bailleurs qui accepte
d'annuler une partie de leur loyer
serait bien possible
on suivra également toutes ces infos en
temps réel sur figaro live bruno le
maire qui nous a dit que et bien toutes
ces mesures représenter un coût total de
15 milliards d'euros par mois de
confinement
à voir donc si ce confinement deuxième
version s'étale au delà du mois de
novembre aussi et bien le 1er décembre
sera bel et bien le retour à ceux de
normal pour bien d'autres sociétés
bonsoir à vous ou steve austin le dit
que c'est un peu la guerre dans le 15e
arrondissement il ya des pompiers qui se
bat contre un feu rue de jouy et en même
temps il ya 100 voitures qui essayent de
joindre le périph ils sont absurdes les
parisiens on va écouter merci de votre
commentaire merci non pas revenir faire
parvenir cette information bonsoir and
killers 84 vous me demandez si les
fast-foods seront ouverts bien en
théorie oui mais que en livraison vous
ne pourrez pas vous y rendre en
présentiel
voilà pour c
ces questions je vais essayer d'en
prendre aussi quelques-unes sur youtube
merci d'être avec nous on prend vos
commentaires je vous le disais tout à
l'heure alors que bien vous êtes
nombreux alors je vois votre question
sur twitch règes vous nous demandez
alors régis 25 930 vous nous demandez
s'il au fil est ouverte alors je vais
regarder ça j'essaie de vous tenir au
courant
entre temps n'hésitez pas à rester avec
nous on pourra prendre un peu plus de
temps pour y répondre
merci à vous d'être avec nous je vous le
disais hé bien pas mal d'informations en
ce qui concerne notamment le télétravail
bah dites nous si vous êtes amené à être
en télétravail
on va on va prendre vos commentaires
avec plaisir voilà ce qu'on a appris non
qui est bien c'est que notamment les
magasins de bricolage parmi beaucoup de
commerces pourront rester ouverts pour
soutenir le monde du btp qui lui aussi a
été particulièrement touché par la crise
on sait aussi qu'un fonds de solidarité
a été enfin le fonds de solidarité
pardon a été renforcée à 6 milliards
d'euros par mois de confinement
je vous disais il ya quelques secondes
et bien le confinement devrait coûter 15
milliards d'euros par mois de
confinement est donc bien ce fonds de
solidarité qui est toujours présent ça
c'est pour vous répondre sur la question
de la précarité notamment qu'on a qu'on
a eu tout à l'heure sur twitch voilà
pour pour ces questions n'hésitez pas à
retrouver ce live en direct vous
directement pardon en vod
si vous souhaitez avoir un peu plus
d'infos sur le monde de l'éducation on a
pu revenir à en direct avec sophie
talent il ya quelques minutes sur les
biens les différentes annonces qui nous
ont qui ne sont parvenus ou et bien
notamment on l'a su le masque est devenu
obligatoire à partir de l'âge de 6 ans
si vous avez donc des petits à la maison
bien ils devront le portait donc à
partir du cp voilà ce qui a été prodigué
on sait aussi et bien que des masques
que les alors je vais essayer de vous
retrouver cette information voilà ce que
olivier verrons nous a expliqué que les
plus vulnérables c'était pour répondre à
une question d'un confrère ou d'une
consoeur n'avait pas besoin de mac de
masques ffp2 mais qu'il pouvait se
contenter de masque bien grand public
voilà pour ce point un peu plus précis
alors je vois beaucoup de commentaires
alors sachez encore que beaucoup de
points sont encore inconnues en ce qui
concerne et bien les les frontières et
bien j'imagine qu'il va falloir se
déplacer pour des raisons essentielles
il va falloir voir si les différents les
différents les différents pays qui sont
ouverts ou non avec leurs frontières
donc là ce sera plutôt du cas par cas
voilà pour cela on le sait donc les
transports et ça c'est pour vous
répondre
zaz ou sont maintenues maintenant la
question c'est de savoir à quel à quelle
fréquence on aura sûrement un peu plus
de détails dans les jours à venir
voilà je vous le rappeler tout à l'heure
on a une liste très longue de commerce
qui sont maintenus ou qui sont fermés
n'hésitez pas à les retrouver en ligne
bonsoir jimmy fn y vous ne posez une
question sur les applications portables
pour les attestations
alors pour le moment l'attestation est
dispo en deux puis techniquement entre
dès 20h30 et 21h sur le site du
gouvernement
donc vous pourrez la retrouver et bien
soit là l'utiliser sur votre téléphone
ou l'imprimer et vous pouvez également
la reproduire sur papier libre en
écrivant et en la réécrivant voilà pour
cette attestation qui a remis un petit
peu de temps à venir on a on
voilà le confinement se fera dans
désormais 3h30 et bien ce sera que dans
les prochaines minutes qu'on pourra
avoir cette attestation
je vois beaucoup beaucoup de deux
questions vous demander notamment si on
peut circuler entre régions et bien ça
dépend de la raison encore une fois là
ce sera du cas par cas si vous vous
déplacez dans une autre région ou bien
il faudra le justifier par votre
attestation
on l'a appris également pour les retours
des vacances de la toussaint et bien de
la tolérance sera maintenue par les
autorités
si vous maintenez via une attestation
écrite ou en tout cas rempli par vos
soins que vous revenez bien de vacances
vous n'êtes pas obligé de revenir en
avance de vos vacances vous pouvez en
tout cas rester jusqu'au point donné par
contre il faudra la tester par l'honneur
ça c'est ce qu'a rapporté jean castex le
premier ministre on le sait aussi qu'une
bien qu'une tolérance sera fait pour les
déménagements ça c'est une information
intéressante pour bien aussi la vie
quotidienne alors du côté des soins ça
c'est pour vous répondre
une dizaine fr sur youtube nous demander
si les dentistes sont maintenus ouverts
bien oui alors du côté de la santé oui
ils sont bel et bien ouvert du côté de
la santé et bien on a appris des mots
d'olivier verront la ministre des
solidarités de la santé qu'un plan blanc
allait être déclenché voilà pour pour
cela alors je vois que vous êtes vous
êtes nombreux sur twitch à nous poser
vos questions alors on avait notamment
cette question de deux régimes de 109 30
qui nous pose une question sur l'eau f
in qui est donc et bien l'office
français de l'immigration et de
l'intégration alors sachez que les
différents guichets de la fonction
publique seront maintenus ouverts alors
on n'a pas eu d'informations précises
sur leur fille
en tout cas eh bien on peut imaginer que
si comme les guichets de mairie et les
différents guichets du service public
bien ils seront maintenus ouverts
bonsoir à vous et re bonsoir c'est doc
sales and killers 84 vous ne posez des
questions on nous demandait si les
techniciens internet pourront toujours
se déplacer chez les personnes qui ont
des problèmes internes est alors là je
suis désolé je n'aurai pas la question
sur
les questions de l'arrivée à domicile
notamment pour les commerces de porte à
porte ou tout ce qui va se faire à
domicile c'est un peu compliqué mais on
peut imaginer que c'est ouvert je vais
essayer de voir si si si j'ai un peu
plus d'informations mais là je pense
qu'il faudrait voir directement avec
votre fournisseur d'accès pour avoir des
bonnes idées des des consignes un peu
plus précise sachant que voilà on
imagine vous imagine mal être sans
téléphone sans électricité ou sans
internet
donc on peut imaginer vu le nombre assez
important de commerce qui peuvent rester
ouverts que cela sera possible
bien évidemment dans le respect du
protocole on sait évidemment je vois que
sur twitch vous avez des questions alors
vous nous demandez royal tofu vous nous
dites je n'ai pas entendu quels sont les
renforcements en protocole sanitaire
pour les établissements alors c'est une
question très vaste en ce qui concerne
les établissements scolaires on sait ils
sont ouverts collèges lycées et reste
ouvert voilà en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement supérieur lui il doit se
faire autant que faire se peut en
télétravail par par distance voilà pour
ces informations là et ensuite eh bien
ce que l'on sait c'est que les
différents établissements de la fonction
publique que restent ouverts en ce qui
concernait bien les différents guichets
que ce soit par exemple pour les impôts
ou les mairies on sait aussi que les
banques elles restent ouvertes
pôle emploi la caf également les agences
d'intérim les bureaux de poste tout cela
reste ouvert
pas d'inquiétude voilà en ce qui
concerne cela les commissariats les
préfectures les banques et assurances je
le disais mais également les les hôtels
et les hébergements de courte durée
lorsqu'il constitue pour les personnes
qui vivent un domicile régulier donc ça
c'est intéressant c'était déjà le cas
pendant bien le premier confinement où
certains hôtel avait été réquisitionné
pour accueillir un maximum de personnes
dans le besoin
on le sait aussi que bien les dans le
même sens les campings et les parcs pour
caravanes ou véhicules de loisirs qui
constitue le domicile régulier de
certaines personnes et bien eux aussi
seront maintenus ouverts voilà pour cela
alors merci bien
julie dans le chat qui m'aide pour la
modération et pour répondre à vos
questions qui nous dit qu'a priori cela
est bien fermée pour l'om riba merci
beaucoup de votre aide
julie dans le tchat bonjour à vous
coderre l'a dit vous le demande et si
les personnes à risque de type diabète
ont un droit de retrait alors ça c'est
une question assez complexe qu'il va
falloir il va falloir attendre un petit
peu pour avoir un peu plus de précision
là dessus
déjà bien prenez soin de vous et faites
très attention va se porter bien les
consignes de distanciation et de
sécurité et n'hésitez pas à nous
retrouver prochainement avec la question
de droit de retrait en ce qui concerne
le monde du travail là est un peu
complexe mais si votre employeur est
bien respectent l'obligation de
télétravail voilà vous pouvez bel et
bien rester chez vous et travailler à
distance
en revanche si votre métier et bien
impose d'être sur place et si vous
faites partie des français concernés par
bien le travail sur place ben voilà fait
faites attention puisque il n'y aura pas
forcément en tout cas de dérogation il
faudra le vérifier il faudra surveiller
sur les jours à venir voilà j'espère
vous apporter un peu de 2 à votre moulin
que d'arles a dit j'en suis désolé je
n'ai pas plus d'informations pour le
moment à savoir encore que confinement
n'a pas encore commencé et qu'on aura
des informations respectives de la part
des différents ministères concernés
au fur et à mesure des jours qui vont
nous parvenir merci à vous sur twitch
pour le follow shivaa 096 wendt aux
reason royal tofu merci beaucoup
rubis 50 54 ll bull tv car aux
photographies merci beaucoup de ces
nombreux follow je vois toujours sur
youtube beaucoup de questions je vais
essayer d'en prendre quelques unes et de
répéter un petit peu certaines choses
qu'on a pu dire et je vais essayer de
vous saluer aussi alors je vois beaucoup
de commentaires et beaucoup de personnes
qui se succèdent
bonjour vous sébastien morel stp jules
rite aid mais albi bastien gier
merci également sur la page principale
du figaro avoue françois terracher par
pragma avec respect nathan 770 merci
vous je vois beaucoup de réactions
beaucoup de réactions qui sont un peu
inquiète de la part de certains d'entre
vous me dites nous ce que vous pensez de
ce confinement si vous pensez que c'est
une bonne chose et que c'est nécessaire
aussi à linverse vous êtes assez
critique comme ces français qui sont à
l'origine d'une manifestation sauvage
qui a rejoint la place de la république
à la rue de rivoli avec milliards entre
150 et 200 personnes
c'est ce que nous rapportent nos
confrères mais également le service info
du figaro voilà on va rester ensemble
encore quelques minutes n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions je vais essayer d'en
prendre
quelques-unes pour vous répondre je vois
notamment les questions interrégions qui
sont va merci de vos de vos questions je
vois notamment voir votre question et
mlilia haarscher nous dit est ce que les
déplacements inter régions sont tolérées
pour emmener quelqu'un à sa ville où il
étudie le week-end surtout pour le
retour de l'individu qui sera seul après
avoir déposé l'étudiant alors là c'est
une question très précis ça va être
difficile de vous répondre en tout cas
sachez que si votre déplacement
peut-être justifiée via l'attestation
c'est possible si ce déplacement se fait
dans le cadre des retours de la
toussaint là aussi vous devez être bien
capable de pouvoir le justifier
via une attestation sur l'honneur mais
voilà le déplacement interrégions et là
vraiment au cas par cas
voilà attention à vous merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi on va se quitter
alors je vous rappelle en tout cas est
ce qui concerne les questions de stage
de bts de prépa et bien on ya répondu à
ces longs moments on l'a répété
plusieurs fois mais sachez en tout cas
que bien les bts et les prépas sont
possibles si jamais cette en prévente
présentiel dans des établissements qui
sont maintenus ouverts
sachez également que les auto écoles
sont fermées mais qu en théorie les
examens sont maintenus en que ben voilà
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner auprès
de votre auto école si vous avez bien
plus d'informations alors demandé si
vous souhaitez savoir un petit peu de
cas par cas je vois notamment votre
question abdellah qui nous posaient des
questions sur les mariages et bien les
mariages sont toujours possibles
en tout cas à la limite de six personnes
présentes
voilà pour cette série de réponses qui
sera la dernière nous allons otites et
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée à
tous n'attendent 770 pragma avec respect
vous aussi françois u/th sur la page
principale du figaro merci à vous sur
twitch tonino 77 ans à qui le lie
bonsoir si je comprends bien
quasiment tout est ouvert sauf pour les
restos bars cinémas alors quasiment tout
n'est pas ouvert hier quand même une
grande liste de
d'établissement qui restent fermés comme
par exemple les établissements de
commerce de gros les bijoutiers et les
horlogers les magasins de jouets les
enseignes dhabi d'habillement les
fleuristes les salons de coiffure les
centres commerciaux de plus de 40 mille
mètres carrés les boîtes de nuit et
discothèques 1 le monde de la nuit bien
évidemment les salles de jeu les stades
hippodrome les parcs de loisirs les
cinémas médiathèques bibliothèques les
salles de spectacle et théâtres les
musées les campagnes de loisirs les
campings de loisirs pardon les monuments
les salles de concerts à la salle
polyvalente les hôtels et les
universités et établissements
d'enseignement supérieur qui eux doivent
largement faire en distance yale pour
les différents courts qui sont maintenus
voilà pour vous répondre que ninon 77 en
vain merci également à vous c'est doc
salle codeurs l'a dit régis 20 930
merci également à vous royal tnt killer
ou encore vous car aux photographies
merci enfin sur youtube de nous avoir
suivis je vois que vous êtes nombreux
encore à poser des questions à réagir
n'hésitez pas à retrouver ce live en
replay si vous souhaitez avoir un peu
plus de
deux questions une information si vous
les avez ratés
voilà merci abdellah merci christopher
abdou 10e à cros rtx camille car emilie
iab
merci beaucoup j'espère avoir pu
répondre à un maximum d'entre vous et
voilà sachez en tout cas que nous sommes
revenus précisément sur les questions de
bts de lycées de cours préparatoire
aussi d'auto école donc n'hésitez pas à
nous retrouver à partir d'une mineure
d'une heure trente six de lecture en vod
pour retrouver les différentes réponses
que nous avons pu vous apportez moi je
vous souhaite à tous une très bonne
soirée sur figaro live et je vous donne
rendez vous très vite pour de nouveaux
stream très bonne soirée à tous